nach meiner kollegin jeanette klag ist
für uns vor ort
ja gut morgen hier aus berlin
tatsächlich auch hier wird es zu beginn
dieser bundestagssitzung einleitende
worte zum gedenken an die queen geben
von bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
auch ist überall auf dem reichstag auch
auf anderen regierungsgebäuden auch auf
den botschaften beispielsweise halbmast
geflaggt hier in berlin auch gestern gab
es übrigens als die nachricht des todes
über die ticker lief hier im bundestag
da saß man noch zusammen sind ja wir
sind ja mitten in den
haushaltsberatungen da wurde die sitzung
kurz unterbrochen und es gab tatsächlich
auch eine gedenk minute also auch hier
auch wenn man mitten in den
haushaltsberatungen steckt spielt es
durchaus zumindest eine kleine rolle
aber wir sind sozusagen am letzten und
vierten tag der haushaltsberatung rund
30 stunden haben die abgeordneten
haushaltsberatungen hier in dieser woche
schon absolviert hat steht noch mal die
schlussrunde hier des haushaltsplanes an
und der einzelplan innen wird heute
nochmal debattiert diese
haushaltsberatungen die standen ganz im
zeichen des angriffskrieges russlands
auf die ukraine die standen im zeichen
der energiekrise der inflation und die
standen auch im zeichen der sorgen der
menschen ob sie sich künftig ihren
alltag überhaupt noch leisten können die
opposition die hat in dieser woche
ausgiebig den haushaltsplan kritisiert
aber auch das dritte entlastungs paket
der bundesregierung und noch mehr die
linke und die afg die wollen im herbst
zu protesten aufrufen gegen die
energiepolitik gegen die sozialpolitik
der bundesregierung und kündigen
wortgleich einen heißen herbst auf den
straßen an in den letzten wochen haben
sicherheitsbehörden gewarnt dass
proteste friedliche proteste
unterwandert werden könnten von
extremisten und dass diese gewalt sogar
das sogar gewalt eskalieren könnte
deswegen wollen wir heute morgen nicht
nur auf den einzelplan innen schauen der
jetzt hier gleich debattiert wird
sondern auch auf dieses thema proteste
und ich darf zwei gäste dazu herzlich
begrüßen zwei innenpolitiker ihrer
fraktion ich darf herzlich begrüßen
sebastian fiedler für die spd-fraktion
mitglied im innenausschuss auch sprecher
für kriminalpolitik der spd-fraktion und
bernd baumann darf ich begrüßen den
ersten parlamentarischen geschäftsführer
der fdp fraktion ebenfalls mitglied im
innenausschuss
herr baumann ihre fraktionsvorsitzende
alles weil hat in der generaldebatte in
dieser woche in richtung bundesregierung
gedroht sie müssen zitat sie haben allen
grund einen heißen herbst und winter zu
fürchten wenn die afg unter diesem motto
zu protesten aufruft welche art von
protest muss man sich unter diesem
begriff heiße herbst vorstellen es ist
ja vieles was im haushalt jetzt im argen
liegt dass man ansprechen muss wir haben
jetzt inneres das thema gerade da wird
die bundespolizei kaputtgespart nach
soll vorgaben planvorgaben sind 400
millionen weniger als im vorjahr das
kann nicht sein der präsident der
bundespolizei sprich dass die
einsatzbereitschaft bedroht ist die
gewerkschaft die bundespolizei spricht
von der katastrophe insgesamt hat die
bevölkerung natürlich alles recht zu
demonstrieren weil grundlegende
politikbereiche die afg hat immer davor
gewarnt einfach danieder liegen wenn man
sich nur mal anguckt die währung euro
inflationsraten wir jetzt die afg war
die partei die davor gewarnt hat
deswegen haben wir uns gegründet weil
der euro falsch aufgestellt ist jetzt
haben der entsetzliche inflationsraten
der euro wird so lira natürlich geht das
volk da auf die straße da schmelzen die
ersparnisse zusammen gleich in der
energiepolitik dass das nicht geht die
afg hat gewarnt da kann ich gleichzeitig
aussteigen aus braunkohle steinkohle
atomkraft kein land der welt macht das
jetzt explodieren die preise nicht nur
wegen putin sondern wegen dieser
falschen politik haben wir auch die
abhängigkeit vom russischen gas das
waren die kabinette merkel und jetzt
scholz die nehmen alle ihr recht in die
hand jetzt auf die straße zu geben wann
wenn ich jetzt bei solcher schieflage
wir müssen nicht darüber sprechen dass
natürlich bürger auf die straße gehen
demonstrationsrecht ist im grundgesetz
verankert natürlich ich wollte mir
daraufhin aus welchen tun die afg
anschlägt weil sie durchaus ja auf
konfrontation gehen und diese proteste
die muss man sich dann gut anschauen
ihre fraktionsvorsitzende weiter hat
gestern als sie ihre kampagne und eine
kundgebung angekündigt haben für anfang
oktober beispielsweise gesagt
deutschland werde absolut für arme und
die menschen würden teilweise ihre jobs
verlieren also mobilisieren sie hier
durch ängste heizen sie diese test
sicher durch ängste bewusst an die
bevölkerung hat doch entsetzliche ängste
da gibt es doch jeden grund dazu wenn
sie sehen wie viele firmen pleite
gemacht haben weil sie die energiekosten
nicht tragen können das geht von kleinen
mittelständischen unternehmen und klein
einzelunternehmern bis hin zu großen
unternehmen wie hackl und so was wir
gehört haben in hamburg werden
produktion eingestellt von großen firmen
das ist der kompass entsetzliches auf
und zu die leute haben die rechnung ja
noch gar nicht in der tasche die haben
jetzt eine ahnung dass alles teurer wird
wenn sie das erst mal haben 60 prozent
haben ja keine ersparnisse das wird eine
entsetzliche situation werden oder gehen
die leute auf die straße die afg
vertritt ihre themen wie sie immer hatte
das sind genau die gleichen themen die
der bevölkerung und dann kann die
innenministerin nicht sagen da kommen
jetzt rechtsradikale und diese
demonstration wäre nicht gerechtfertigt
wenn delegitimiert das ging eigentlich
das falsche demokratie ja nicht genau
wie ich habe ja ich habe ja sozusagen
auch gefragt nach ihrer kundgebung herr
fiedler bundeskanzler olaf scholz sagt
er rechnet nicht mit unruhen mit
sozialen unruhen im herbst hat auch
darauf hingewiesen es gibt das dritte
entlastungspaket trotzdem am montag
haben menschen bereits in leipzig auch
in magdeburg demonstriert auch gegen die
energiepolitik der bundesregierung etwas
rechnen sie
wenn sie gestatten es einsatz schon noch
dazu sagen die afg spricht nicht für die
bevölkerung sowie das gerade so
suggeriert wird sondern es gibt einen
unterschied der politischen kräfte das
muss man vielleicht erklären dass auch
ein großer erklärung sozusagen für ihre
frage es gibt eben die politischen
parteien zu denen ich die kfd jetzt
nicht rechnet die sozusagen darum bemüht
sind den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
in dieser schwierigen situation
krisensituation zu stärken die alle
politischen bemühungen darauf stützen
und die ard versucht immer den spaltpilz
in der gesellschaft zu identifizieren
und ihre themen danach auszurichten wie
sie diesen spaltpilz immer tiefer
treiben kann und das ist sozusagen der
grund für die beteiligung jetzt an
diesen protesten das herbeireden von
immer noch schlimmeren
untergangsszenarien das sind die großen
unterschiede so und womit wir rechnen
ist natürlich dass es keine neue
situation die sicherheitsbehörden sagen
dass schon lange es hat sich mindestens
in den anti corona protesten gezeigt
dass wir einen neuen extremismus sehen
ich nenne den vereinfacht verschwörungs
extremismus und wir erkennen ja dass
dieselben leute die sich gegen die
korona maßnahmen gestimmt haben
dieselben die putin fans jetzt geworden
sind in den entsprechenden kanälen das
sind dieselben die jetzt vor
untergangsszenarien waren und es werden
auch dieselben sein die irgendwann vor
einer sogenannten klima diktatur waren
das heißt sie habe schon damals gesagt
dieser extremismus bleibt uns erhalten
und die afg springt hier drauf natürlich
und versucht möglichst anzuheizen die
vokabel heißer herbst bedeutet ja sie
ist nicht etwa bemüht den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt zu
stärken sondern wir sollten schon genau
darauf schauen welche politischen kräfte
versuchen den noch zu verstärken und
noch anzuheizen während wir hier glaube
ich mit dem bild besser bedient sind
denn die sind als bunte in der
bundeskanzler immer versucht
unterzubringen wir müssen uns unterhaken
wert und wir müssen sehen wie wir durch
diese zeit kommen und ich glaube man
kann wirklich sagen die bundesregierung
hat wirklich alles getan mit großen
unterstützungsmaßnahmen für wirtschaft
und bevölkerung dass das auch gelingen
kann trotzdem muss man fragen wie soll
denn der bürger der auf die straße geht
der demonstriert im herbst unterscheiden
können ihre innenministerin hat gesagt
ja die demonstranten müssten sich
sozusagen
distanzieren von extremisten aber
selbstverständlich also wie soll das
entscheiden könnt also ist wird er zur
demonstration angemeldet und ich würde
nicht im leben auf die idee kommen wenn
die freien sachsen oder die afg eine
demonstration anmeldet mich da in diese
demonstration zu begeben also da muss
ich schon unterscheiden es gibt eben
parteien die stehen im
verfassungsschutzbericht aus guten
gründen weil sie antidemokratisch
unterwegs sind und es gibt eben solche
die zum demokratischen spektrum gehören
die sich um den zusammenhalt der
gesellschaft bemühen die sorgen ernst
nehmen wollen und da gibt's natürlich
ein legitimes interesse zu demonstrieren
dass geht darum wo wird angeheizt und
die ried das risiko erhöht dass es zu
gewalttaten kommt und da unterscheiden
sich die parteien sehr
sie werden auch sozusagen seit' an seit'
auch mit der linken ja diese
demonstration anmelden unter dem
gleichen begriff nämlich heiße herbst
sie muss man sich das vorstellen
zunächst machen war zum vorredner also
dass da jetzt rechts und rechtsradikale
unterwegs sind das mag sein an der einen
oder anderen stelle das muss bekämpft
werden aber die demonstrations- gründe
diese
pflanze und inflation die
inflation die ganze energie politik dass
die dass die innenminister ihrer ihre
verfassungsschutzämter missbrauchen die
ihm unterstellt sind das ist klar zudem
hat die grünen legen die wünsche der
bevölkerung ist legitim er versucht
jetzt auch jeder dass zu delegitimieren
das seien hier die bevölkerung wird
demonstrieren aus gutem recht von der
generellen diskussion noch weiterführen
an anderer stelle ich danke ganz
herzlich dass sie heute morgen da waren
und ich gebe rhein zu bärbel bas in den
sand
sid
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
wir gedenken heute ihrer majestät
königin
elizabeth die zweite
königin des vereinigten königreichs
großbritannien mit britannien und
nordirland
königin elizabeth die zweite verstarb
gestern im alter von 96 jahren
über 70 jahre war sie staatsoberhaupt
des vereinigten königreichs und der
anderen staaten des commonwealth
so lange wie kein britischer monarch vor
ihr die meisten menschen können sich
eine welt ohne königin elizabeth die
zweite nicht vorstellen
sie war die monarchen des jahrhunderts
1926 geboren umfasst die ihr leben tief
greifende politische und soziale
umbrüche im vereinigten königreich und
in europa
sie erlebte den zweiten weltkrieg das
ende des britischen
kolonialreichs
entschuldigung den kalten krieg und den
fall der mauer
den nordirland-konflikt
den beitritt könig großbritanniens zum
europäischen union und auch den br- exit
und die korona pandemie
sie stand für frieden in europa und
sorgte sich schon vor jahren dass eine
neue trennlinien in europa drohte
erst im juni hat das vereinigte
königreich ihr 70 thron jubiläum
gefeiert es waren tage der freude und
des stolzes auf die queen als
staatsoberhaupt
im vereinigten königreich und im
gesamten commonwealth sie führte ein
leben im dienst ihres volkes mit
klarsicht weisheit und großer disziplin
aber auch mit humor hat sie den
zusammenhalt im vereinigten königreich
gestärkt zur neutralität verpflichtet
wirkte sie mit ihrer moralischen
autorität
königin elizabeth die zweite stand für
werte und beständigkeit in sieben
jahrzehnten die die ich so viele
tiefgreifenden umbrüchen geprägt waren
sie war eine ausnahmepersönlichkeit und
ein vorbild weit über die grenzen des
vereinigten königsreichs hinaus überall
auf der welt genoss die respekt
bewunderung und sympathien das lag auch
an ihrem einsatz für den frieden wir
deutschen sind ihr zutiefst dankbar
dafür
während ihrer regentschaft wurde aus den
beziehungen der einstigen kriegsgegner
großbritannien und deutschland eine
freundschaft daran hatte königin
elizabeth die zweite die im zweiten
weltkrieg in der frauenabteilung des
britischen heeres diente erheblichen
anteil bei ihrem staatsbesuch
2015 der ihr letzter staatsbesuch
überhaupt bleiben sollte bezeichnete sie
die beziehungen zwischen unseren ländern
als eine der unumkehrbaren veränderungen
zum besseren in ihrer lebenszeit es ging
ihr wie sie es ausdrückte um eine
vollständige aussöhnung immer wieder hat
sie sich für diese aussöhnung und
freundschaft stark gemacht welche
bedeutung unsere verständigung für sie
hatte zeigen ihre vielen und
ausführlichen staatsbesuche in
deutschland die uns noch in klarer und
sehr guter erinnerung sind auch die die
jahrzehnte zurückliegen
jeder ihrer besuche in deutschland
brachte viele tausend bewunderer auf die
straße britische medien berichteten 1965
über ein wahres queen fieber in
deutschland
als erstes britisches staatsoberhaupt
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg und erste
britische monarchin seit 1909 besuchte
die queen
1965 die bundesrepublik deutschland
elf tage lang reiste die königin
begleitet von ihrem mann prinz philip
damals durch die bundesrepublik 20
stationen umfasste diese erste reise
darunter auch meine heimatstadt duisburg
immer wieder besuchte sie danach
deutschland sie reißt so reiste sie im
oktober 1992 fünf tage durch das
wiedervereinte deutschland
deutschland hat königin elizabeth die
zweite viel zu verdanken
trotz aller schwierigen phasen die in
ihre regentschaft vielen setzte sie sich
bis an ihr lebensende für zusammenhalt
und zuversicht ein in ihrer
grußbotschaft an ihr volk zum 70
thronjubiläum sagte sie
in dem wir darüber nachdenken was wir in
den letzten 70 jahren erreicht haben
blicken wir auch der zukunft mit
zuversicht und enthusiasmus entgegen
wir trauern um eine große staatsfrau der
königlichen familie und dem vereinigten
königreich gilt unser tief empfundenes
mitgefühl
wir stehen in diesem moment der trauer
fest an der seite
des vereinigten königreichs ich möchte
sie nun bitten sich als zeichen des
respekts unserer dankbarkeit und unserer
trauer im gedenken an ihre majestät
königin elizabeth die zweite königin des
vereinigten königreichs großbritannien
und nordirland von den plätzen zu
erheben für eine schweigeminute
ich danke ihnen bitte nehmen sie wieder
platz
wir setzen nun die haushaltsberatungen
fort
für die heutige aussprache haben wir am
dienstag eine redezeit von insgesamt
drei stunden beschlossen ich rufe nun
den geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums des inneren und
heimat auf und zuerst hat das wort für
die bundesregierung die bundesministerin
nancy faeser
dankeschön frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren sehr geehrte
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages
fällt nicht ganz leicht nach dem
gedenken an kreml ist es hier
weiterzumachen ich möchte aber noch
einmal hervorheben dass gerade sie es
war die in sieben jahrzehnten auch immer
für den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
geworben hat und darüber können wir
glaube ich gerade die brücke ins
innenministerium schlagen weil das ist
gerade dieser tage wichtiger denn je
meine damen und herren der krieg in der
ukraine hat dramatische auswirkungen in
erster linie natürlich für die menschen
im land und ich konnte mich vor wenigen
wochen ja auch selbst davon überzeugen
wie schwierig es ist und aber auch in
deutschland wirkt sich der krieg massiv
aus ich kann gut verstehen dass viele
menschen in deutschland dieser tage auch
verunsichert sind steigende
lebensmittelpreise hohe energiepreise
energie mangel und ja natürlich auch
durch neue bedrohungen der inneren
sicherheit wir erleben wie die russische
regierung gezielt des informationen
verbreitet um gerade auch unsere
gesellschaft zu spalten und ich werbe an
dieser stelle dafür sich bei
verschiedenen quellen zu informieren und
nicht auf das reinzufallen was im
internet auf zu lesen ist
wir sehen ein erhöhtes risiko von cyber
angriffen auf unternehmen behörden und
kritische infrastruktur in unserem land
und wir erleben natürlich schmerzlich
dass unsere sicherheit in deutschland
eben nicht selbstverständlich ist
sondern dass wir dafür auch etwas tun
müssen die herausforderung im bereich
der inneren sicherheit sind sehr groß
und klar ist wir als bundesregierung
stellen uns diesen herausforderungen wir
handeln wir investieren in die
sicherheit der menschen in deutschland
meine damen und herren
für mich steht fest auch und gerade in
schwierigen zeiten muss unsere
sicherheit absolute priorität haben
dafür steht der vorliegende
haushaltsentwurf auch ein er sieht für
den einzelplan das bundesministerium des
innern ein gesamtvolumen von rund 12,7 6
milliarden vor das sind 1 5 milliarden
euro mehr als in der ursprünglichen
finanzplanung meine damen und herren und
auch das sollte man dieser tage zur
kenntnis nehmen
in den jahren 2020 bis 22 hatten wir
durch die konjunkturpakete während der
korona pandemie sehr große auf höchste
für das bmi die haben wir für
vorgezogene investitionen insbesondere
im bereich der sicherheitsbehörden und
für den bevölkerungsschutz investiert
und das war auch richtig das war aber
nur möglich weil die schuldenbremse
ausgesetzt war ich will das ausdrücklich
noch einmal hervorheben der haushalt
2023 hält die schuldenbremse nun wieder
ein und auch das und das will ich noch
mal vor heben an dieser stelle ist in
zeiten der unsicherheit eine form der
stabilität die gut und richtig ist
im einzelplan des innenministeriums
macht der sicherheitsbereich mehr als
die hälfte des budgets aus wir reden
hier von 6,5 milliarden euro und das
sind fast 200 millionen mehr als in der
ursprünglichen finanzplanung
besonders wichtig ist mir dass das
technische hilfswerk und das bsi sowie
das vollzugspersonal der bundespolizei
und des bka von den pauschalen
stellenkürzungen im personalbereich
ausgenommen sind ich denke bei den
verwaltungs beamtinnen und beamten
müssen wir noch ein wenig nachbessern
weil auch das hat auswirkungen auf die
vollzugsbeamten meine damen und herren
und es gibt selbst in diesen schwierigen
situationen stellen auf höchste im
sicherheitsbereich die bundespolizei
erhält 1000 zusätzliche stellen das bka
180 das ist ein großer erfolg und eine
wichtige investition in unsere
gemeinsame sicherheit meine damen und
herren ich bin im finanzminister
ausdrücklich dankbar dafür dass er
diesen weg mitgegangen ist
wem aber dieser tage angesichts der
hohen bedrohungslagen der veränderten
sicherheitslage mein größtes dankeschön
gilt ist den mitarbeitern mitarbeitern
der sicherheitsbehörden und zwar aller
sicherheitsbehörden vom bsi angefangen
über das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
der bundespolizei natürlich an
vorderster stelle aber auch gerade dem
bka herzlichen dank für das was sie in
schweren zeiten leisten sie stellt die
sicherheit in unserem land da und wir
stehen voll hinter ihnen
seit dem russischen angriff auf die
ukraine hat sich besonders natürlich die
bedrohungslage im cyber raum erheblich
erhöht das nehmen wir sehr ernst und
haben alle schutz massiven maßnahmen
massiv hochgefahren
ich bin deshalb sehr froh dass die
behörden die für cyber sicherheit
zuständig sind mit dem haushalt 2023 gut
ausgestattet werden hervorheben möchte
ich dass das bmw für die härtung der
netze des bundes jährlich 300 millionen
zusätzlich erhält für digitalisierung
und cyber sicherheit stehen insgesamt
rund 1,6 milliarden euro bereit damit
machen wir im bereich der cyber
sicherheit einen großen schritt nach
vorne aber ja wir müssen noch mehr tun
und in unserer cybersicherheit agenda
haben wir uns viel vorgenommen für die
zukunft wir werden in den nächsten zehn
jahren etwa 20 milliarden insgesamt
investieren müssen dass es geld viel
geld sehr viel geld aber
sicherheit gibt es auch in den bereichen
nicht zum nulltarif meine damen und
herren
und ich will das ausdrücklich betonen
die bedrohung putins in der ukraine und
die folgen des furchtbaren krieges haben
natürlich massive auswirkungen auf die
innere sicherheit und deswegen erleben
wir auch eine zeitenwende in der inneren
sicherheit und das weiß auch der
finanzminister meine damen und herren
in der aktuellen lage steht das thema
bevölkerungsschutz zu recht besonders im
fokus es ist völlig klar wir müssen
unser land krisenfester machen wir
müssen uns besser gegen bedrohungen aber
auch gegen klimafolgen wappnen und wir
müssen die bevölkerung besser schützen
der bevölkerungs und katastrophenschutz
wird deshalb gegenüber der finanzplanung
und 145 millionen gestärkt und es werden
146 neue stellen für das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
geschaffen das ist ein großer schritt
nach vorne meine damen und herren
aber es ist auch klar auch hier müssen
wir weiter sehr viel in den nächsten
jahren investieren da gilt das gleiche
wie in der cyber sicherheit das ist der
bereich der natürlich durch einen krieg
mitten in europa sich verändert hat und
erhebliche investitionen in der zukunft
nach sich ziehen wird aber an dieser
stelle werde ich auch noch einmal dafür
das ist eine gemeinschaftsleistung aller
bundesländer und des bundes ist und
nicht alleine beim bund abgeladen werden
darf meine damen und herren
thb und bbk stehen im regierungsentwurf
2023 über eine halbe milliarde euro zur
verfügung damit werden wir die bahn
strukturen in den ländern weiter
modernisieren wir werden den schutz vor
chemischen biologischen und nuklearen
gefahren erhöhen wir werden die
notstromversorgung der kritischen
infrastruktur verbessern und auch in das
projekt labor 5000 weiter investieren
weil es so wichtig ist für die
verschiedenen krisen lagen auch
unterschiedlich gewappnet zu sein die
mittel
die mittel für das technische hilfswerk
sollen vor allen dingen der
unterstützung der thw ortskräfte dienen
wir modernisieren die ausstattung des
thws weiter stärken seine operativen
fähigkeiten
außerdem investieren wir den auf und
ausbau der thw logistikzentren all das
diente inneren sicherheit in unserem
land meine damen und herren und mein
besonderes dankeschön gilt all
denjenigen die im einsatz im namen des
thws unterwegs waren bei ihrem größten
einsatz im a teil ihrer geschichte in
der bundesrepublik deutschland aber auch
natürlich jetzt in unmittelbarer hilfe
für die ukraine
herzlichen dank an die vielen vielen
tausenden ehrenamtlich tätigen aber auch
die hauptamtlichen des thws
es gibt einen bereich der sehr wichtig
ist für den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt und das ist der sport und
deswegen werden wir gerade in diesem
jahr gegen ende des jahres nochmal
massiv dafür werben die örtlichen
sportvereine zu unterstützen mit unserem
sport programm restart aber auch
natürlich mit einem bewegungs gipfel der
die zukunft des sportlers noch mal
besonders hervorheben wird ich bin
dankbar dafür dass die
haushaltspolitikerin diesen weg auch
mitgegangen sind vielen dank dafür
vor uns liegen große herausforderung
meine damen und herren das spornt mein
haus an der haushaltsentwurf für das
jahr 2023 stärkt die innere sicherheit
und er bietet eine gute grundlage um die
vorhaben des bmi in allen
politikbereichen voranzubringen auch mit
der einhaltung der schuldenbremse und
zuletzt bedanke ich mich noch mal ganz
ganz herzlich bei den haushalts
politikerinnen und politikern
insbesondere der koalition bei famila
schäfer bei dr thorsten liegt bei martin
gerster herzlichen dank für die gute
zusammenarbeit aber auch an herrn dr
berg von der cdu und herr petri von der
linkspartei vielen dank für dieses
gemeinsame unterstützen der inneren
sicherheit
die bundesjustizministerin nancy faeser
hier zu ihrem etat mit dem sie ganz
zufrieden ist allerdings muss sie
zumindest was der entwurf sagt fürs
nächste jahr mit etwas weniger geld
auskommen mal schauen was die cdu csu
fraktion dazu zu sagen hat alexander
throm sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
hörte kolleginnen und kollegen wenn man
über den haushalt des innenministeriums
etwas positives sagen will dann ist es
aus finanzpolitischer sicht ein
sparhaushalt aber genau das ist das
problem aus innenpolitischer sicht ist
es eine katastrophe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen frau
ministerin sie haben gesagt wir haben
die zeitenwende ja wir haben eine
zeitenwende nur in ihrem haushalt ist
davon nichts zu erkennen sie kürzen den
etat des innern von fast 15 milliarden
euro um 2,3 milliarden euro auf 12,7
milliarden euro das ist innenpolitisch
ein offenbarungseid
sie fahren
sie fallen damit zurück auf den stand
von 2017 und nicht 2020 wo die
konjunktur gelder eingestellt wurden
2017 das war weit vor dem kriegen der
ukraine weit vor corinna weit vor den
fluten und ihr vergleich mit der
finanzplanung frau ministerin wird
schlicht hilflosen wie mir sicher sie
haben beim finanzminister für mehr
geworden aber verloren ihre
amtsvorgänger haben jeweils steigend der
ansätze in ihren haushalten einwerben
können offensichtlich ist bei der ampel
die innenpolitik die innere sicherheit
nicht so hoch angesehen ein frau
ministerin sie sind das letzte jahr
durch das land gereist haben wie die
ankündigungen gemacht aber von umsetzung
keine spur sie können mit diesen zahlen
nicht das halten was sie versprochen
haben
wir haben natürlich eine zeitenwende
seit dem 24 februar so dass wir die
sicherheitsbehörden auch entsprechend
aufstellen müssen und auch aufrüsten das
sagt wer das sagen sie frau faeser am 88
bei der welt die sicherheitsbehörden
auch aufrüsten müssen aufrüsten heißt so
sie ein - im sicherheitsbereich von über
1,4 milliarden euro allein bei der
bundespolizei 400 millionen weniger und
das in einer zeit der migrations krise
in das in einer zeit von flut und
anderen dingen und wo sie ankündigen
dass wir einen schwierigen winter uns
haben frau ministerin das passt nicht
zusammen und dann haben sie ihre
weiteren ankündigungen in der bild
zeitung dass die kreis und hetze haben
soll auch gesagt bekämpfen wollen und
ihre weiteren ankündigung dass sie
insbesondere kinderpornografie
kindesmissbrauch bekämpfen wollen doch
überhaupt nicht umgesetzt auch bei bka
sparen sie zwar nur 25 millionen aber
sie kürzen dort und das passt mit ihren
versprechungen nicht zusammen sie sind
schlicht eine ankündigungsministerin
[Applaus]
muss sie sprechen dann von einem
neustart im bevölkerungsschutz so
jedenfalls die erfindung ihrer pr
abteilung sie haben dabei wird übersehen
dass der neustart bereits 2019 begonnen
hat ihr neustart ist ein fehlstart weit
sie kürzen beim thw um 40 prozent und
bei bbk um 30% das passt nicht zusammen
sie waren auf der innenministerkonferenz
dieses frühe die innenminister am zehn
milliarden euro mehr in bevölkerung und
zivilschutz gefordert in zehn jahren und
sie haben dem zugestimmt jedenfalls
haben die energie ist dass sie so
verstanden dass diese forderung von
ihnen unterstützt wird sie gehen zurück
als nach vorne und das ist nicht in
ordnung und nicht verantwortbar eine
kolleginnen und kollegen
nur ein kleines beispiel
sie haben irgendwann diesen sommer davon
gesprochen dass ehrenamtliche früher in
rente gehen sollen
gerade da wo es darum geht ehrenamtliche
zu gewinnen beispielsweise bei der
helfer gewinnung für das thw machen sie
eine vollbremsung praktisch auf null von
7,6 millionen auf 0,6 millionen im
nächsten jahr damit kann die helfer
gewinnung nicht mehr in dem maße
stattfinden wie es das thw und für einen
residenten bevölkerungsschutz auch
notwendig ist frau ministerin ihnen war
die schlagzeile wichtig als tatsächlich
ehrenamtliche zu fördern und zu gewinnen
und in der migrationspolitik sieht es
ähnlich aus sie sprechen immer so schön
von einem paradigmenwechsel den sie
anstellen wollen dazu sollen die
integrationskurse für alle von anfang an
geöffnet werden der haushalt sagt was
anderes da werden die mittel für
integrationskurse gekürzt um 10 prozent
und für migrationsberatung für
erwachsene gar um 23 prozent liebe
kollegen kollegen von der ampeln
insbesondere von den grünen das hätte
sich ein unions-innenminister einmal
trauen sollen in einer solchen situation
wo wir mehr zuwanderung aus mit flucht
hintergrund haben in deutschland als
jemals zuvor und
an frau ministerin verkünden sie einen
durchbruch in der europäischen
migrationspolitik beim gipfel der
innenminister im juni und ehrlich gesagt
ich war zunächst auch durchaus
beeindruckt allerdings im negativen
sinne weil ich schlimmeres also
schlimmes befürchtet haben ein paar tage
später nach ihrer großen pressemeldung
siege dann durch das sich die
innenminister europas auf ganze 10.000
menschen geeinigt haben wurde die sie
verteilen wollen ihre frau ministerin
das ist kein durchbruch das ist schlicht
eine luftnummer angesichts der quantität
angesichts der quantität herr kollege
hören sie zu wir haben jeden monat in
deutschland 10.000 menschen die kommen
aus syrien afghanistan und dem irak im
august man es 16.000 erstanträge
wachsend insgesamt
132000 da haben wir die menschen aus der
ukraine da mehr die menschen ich hab
noch gar nicht angefangen bleiben sie
doch mal ruhig da waren die menschen aus
der ukraine noch gar nicht noch gar
nicht dabei die länder die kommunen
schreien alarm die ersten hallen werden
belegt sie sind sich dieser realität
offensichtlich in der ampel und sie frau
ministerin auch nicht bewusst sie
schreiben presseerklärung wo sie in
blumigen worten danke sagen bei den
kommen sie brauchen hilfe wir brauchen
unterstützung sie brauchen vor allem
eine migration steuerung die dafür sorgt
dass sie entlastet werden und dazu zug
nicht täglich gesteigert hat
noch etwas sie haben bei diesem
angeblichen durchbruch gesagt dass die
länder die sich bei der aufnahme nicht
beteiligen wollen sich finanziell
entsprechend engagieren so und ich habe
sie gefragt diesen sommer mit einer
abgeordneten anfrage da musste ihrem
ministerium antworten dass es im
ministerium über diese zahlung keinerlei
erkenntnisse gibt frau ministerin sie
sind mehr interessiert an der großen
schlagzeile als an der tatsächlichen
problemlösung
und ungeachtet
der zeitenwende halten sie an ihrem
paradigmenwechsel in der
migrationspolitik fest als ob wir nicht
das jahr hätten mit der höchsten
zuwanderung in deutschland als ob wir
nicht den krieg in der ukraine wetten
dass sie mich nicht falsch verstehen wir
wollen den ukrainerinnen ukraine helfen
aber beenden sie ihre
migrationspolitische geisterfahrt sie
fahren in die andere richtung als alle
anderen europäischen länder dort wird
nämlich illegale migration begrenzt sie
dagegen öffnen der illegalen migration
durch anreize und pool effekte tür und
tor sie begehen damit einen sonderweg in
europa und das ist in diesen zeiten
nicht richtig
und zum schluss ein kleiner
tipp für ihren sparhaushalt wenn sie
schon neun monate den sonder
bevollmächtigten für
rückführungsabkommen nicht besitzen und
auch ihren migrations staatssekretär
dann streichen sie diese personal
einsätze einfach im haushalt und sie
sind weiter liegt kind beim
finanzminister herzlichen dank
alexander throm war dass politiker csu
fraktion deren innenpolitischer sprecher
hier schon mal mit einem vorgeschmack
was da an kritik an diesem etat
zumindest aus den reihen der cdu csu
fraktion
geäußert wird was man dann mit in die
haushaltsberatungen natürlich in
annehmen wird jetzt vermittler schäfer
für die grüne
und kollegen liebe in ministerin fehler
vor 50 jahren
wurden elf israelische sportler und ein
bayerischer polizist von der
palästinensischen terrorgruppe schwarzer
september bei den olympischen spielen in
münchen 1972 ermordet die fehler der
deutschen behörden sind gravierend weder
ausmaß und der antisemitische kontext
der tat wurde bis heute verstanden oder
ausreichend aufgearbeitet
deshalb bin ich frau innenministerin
phaser sehr dankbar dass sie das
versagen unserer gesellschaft und
unserer behörden klar benannt hat dass
sie eine unabhängige kommission zur
untersuchung dieser fehler einberufen
hat und dass sie mit uns gemeinsam im
haushaltsausschuss nun endlich die
entschädigungszahlungen für die opfer
auf den weg gebracht hat für die
sicherheit in vielen dank
das hätte ich damals nicht sagen an der
stelle
in der vergangenheit haben wir auch
schon gut zusammengearbeitet an dem
haushalt und ich will zu ehrlich sagen
wir müssen auch wieder gut zusammen
arbeiten an diesen haushalten es gibt
noch parlamentarischen
nachbesserungsbedarf
denn leider wurde die abmachung in der
bundesregierung nicht eingehalten dass
wir sauber abwehr uns die gier schutz
ausreichend aus finanzieren weil das
jetzt nicht im sondervermögen mit
abgebildet ist das wurde versprochen
haushalt zu machen da gibt es aber noch
nachbesserungsbedarf
und das ist notwendig weil wir ja nicht
nur unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
besser ausrüsten wollen sondern
natürlich auch diejenigen die in
katastrophen- oder kriegsfeld unsere
eigenen bevölkerung schützen und auch
das aartal hat gezeigt probleme bei der
bahn infrastruktur oder bei den meldet
hätten die können verheerend die können
tödlich sein und die klimakrise zeigt
doch extreme trockenheit waldbrände
flutkatastrophen dass wir zu nehmen
darum können wir uns doch jetzt nicht
leisten was die tam zivilschutz zu
sparen wenn wir die investitionsstaus
jetzt nicht abbauen dann wird uns das am
ende doch noch viel teurer zu stehen
kommt
und auch und auch die cyber residenz zu
stärken die kritische infrastruktur zu
stärken ist natürlich wichtiger der nähe
denn viel wahrscheinlicher als dass
putin uns mit konventionellen waffen
angreift ist es oft dass er
beispielsweise unsere krankenhäuser oder
unsere wasserinfrastruktur hecken wird
wir dürfen hier investitionen nicht
zurückhalten und daher müssen wir diesen
bereich jetzt auch noch mal stärker in
den blick nehmen und auch im sinne von
krisenprävention ist es die integration
weiter zu stärken wir brauchen
integrationskurse und gut ausgestattetes
fachpersonal in dem bereich nicht nur
aus moralischen gründen um unsere
kommunen zu stärken sondern auch um den
fachkräftemangel in diesem land zu
bekämpfen
ich möchte noch einen letzten punkt
ansprechen der auch mir besonders
wichtig ist im koalitionsvertrag haben
wir einen bundes aufnahmeprogramm für
besonders gefährdete menschen aus
afghanistan vereinbart und ein jahr nach
dem katastrophalen abzug der truppen
sitzen noch immer viele menschen fest
und verstecken sich von den taliban wir
sollten unser versprechen sie zu
schützen nun endlich einlösen dafür
zähle auf ihre unterstützung frau feser
und sie kann auch auf unsere
unterstützung hier im parlament sehen
die aufgaben sind groß aber wir haben
schon im letzten parlamentarischen
verfahren viel gewuppt dafür auch noch
mal vielen dank an meine mit
berichterstatter insbesondere an
thorsten lieb und martin gerster ich
freue mich auf die konstruktive
zusammenarbeit auch mit dem
bundesinnenministerium vielen dank
schäfer bades für die piste sie sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss redner für die afg
von da wird man dann an diesem
einzelplan in den nächsten wochen noch
einiges arbeit im november soll dann
erst der bundeshaushalt hier endgültig
verabschiedet werden martin hess für die
acht
wichtigsten aufgabe nachkommen und
sicherheit und schutz für die bürger in
unserem land gewährleisten will muss
zwingend eine ideologiefreie lageanalyse
betreiben und dann alle zur stärkung der
inneren sicherheit erforderlichen
maßnahmen treffen aber sie frau
innenministerin sie tun ständig und
beharrlich das gegenteil wenn man ihr
handeln betrachtet muss man ganz klar
feststellen noch nie zuvor war das amt
des bundesinnenministers von einer
dermaßen ideologisch formierten und die
realität nahezu vollständig
ignorierenden person besetzen beispiel
islamismus es kann niemand ernsthaft
bezweifeln dass der politische islam und
der islamistische terror eine massive
sicherheitsgefahr für unser land
darstellen die habt um den schlossen
bekämpft werden muss aber was tut die
innenministerin sie stellt ernsthaft die
arbeit des expertenkreises politische
islamismus beim bmw ein wer bisher immer
dachte dass sie lediglich unfähig
dilettantisch oder schlicht mit ihrem
amt auf andere weise überfordert wären
der wird nun eines besseren belehrt sie
verweigern mit wissen und wollen die
effektive bekämpfung des islamismus in
unserem land das kommt einer
kapitulation vom islamistischem
verbrechern gleich und damit sind sie
als innenministerin völlig untragbar
genauso unverantwortlich einen bundes
widersinnig ist ihr handeln im bereich
der migrationspolitik sie beklagen
völlig zurecht ständig die gewalt gegen
wie sie es nennen quere personen aber
lassen auch für jahr in unser land
zehntausende menschen die aufgrund ihrer
meist islamistischen sozialisation genau
diesen hass mitbringen und in unserem
land auch umsetzen aus jüngst wurde der
trans man mal der motor der täter war
und das ist inzwischen ja in unserem
land zu einem muster geworden ein wegen
gewaltdelikten verurteilt muslimischen
flüchtlingen hätten sie diesen
gewaltverbrecher nie ins land gelassen
oder ihn wenigstens abgeschoben dann
wären alte folgte noch am leben nehmen
sie das endlich zur kenntnis auch die
explodierende messe kriminalität in
unserem land wird von ihnen moniert was
sie aber beharrlich ignorieren ist dass
der anteil ausländischer tatverdächtiger
exorbitant hoch und zb in baden
württemberg schon seit jahren über 50
prozent liegt ist ihre migrationspolitik
verschlechtert die sicherheitslage in
unserem land von tag zu tag effektiver
grenzschutz und abschiebung und sind das
gebot der stunde und das muss jetzt
endlich umgesetzt werden und hören sie
auch ständig legitimen bürgerprotest zu
diffamieren dass durch die einführung
des phänomen bereichs verfassungsschutz
relevante wegen sanierung des staates
jetzt nahezu jeder bürger oder die
regierung habt und überspitzt kritisiert
in gefahr geraten kann vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet zu werden
ist für überzeugte und aufrechte
demokraten nicht hinnehmbar und muss
schnellstens korrigiert werden denn die
begründung dass durch allzu scharf
formulierte kritik an der regierung das
vertrauen in den staat verloren geht ist
ja hanebüchen merken sie sich einst
vertrauen in den staat geht nicht durch
kritik an der regierung verloren dort
sondern durch ihre desaströse politik
die katastrophale folgen für die bürger
unseres landes hat und wenn durch ihre
fatalen fehlentscheidungen herbst und
winter für tausende bürger das leben
unbezahlbar wird unzählige firmen
pleitegehen und die arbeitslosigkeit
explodiert dann ist es das
grundgesetzlich verbriefte recht eines
jeden bürgers unseres landes auf die
straße zu gehen und der regierung auch
und gerade in schonungslos und direkter
form die rote karte zu zeigen und wer
diese berechtigt proteste wie sie da
ständig tun als rechtsextrem diffamiert
und das sogar präventiv aber
gleichzeitig aktionen von files for
future oder black rider aus
ideologischen gründen ausdrücklich
begrüßt der beschädigt unsere demokratie
und verhält sich eines innenministers
unterrichtsministerin sie sind nicht nur
eine ideologisch verblendete
sicherheitspolitische geisterfahrerin
und damit eine glatte fehlbesetzung in
unserem land nein sie sind wesentlich
mehr sie sind eine massive gefahr für
die innere sicherheit und die demokratie
in unserem land je früher sie abtreten
desto besser für uns alle
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion dr
thorsten liebt
und er sitzt für die liberalen im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin 7 frau
bundesministerin feser liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
ich find's einfach unfassbar welche
propaganda man sich hier von diesem
rednerpult in diesem hohen hause anhören
muss das war ein neuer richtung der
haushaltsdebatte in dieser woche
wir beraten
wir beraten heute über den einzelplan
des bundesministeriums des inneren und
für heime ist ja gut ich habe es
verstanden in einer denkwürdigen woche
diesen montag wurde
endlich und überfällig haben das gleich
danke eine vereinbarung zwischen der
bundesrepublik deutschland und den
israelischen hinterbliebenen des olympia
attentat wissen sie ich rede über ein
attentat von vor 50 jahren sie haben
nichts besseres zu tun als reinzureden
das nenne ich mal eine respektvolle
debatte geehrte kolleginnen politik
die entschädigungszahlung 28 millionen
euro die an erkennungsleistung war
überfällig und es war zeit nach 50
jahren gibt es eine lösung ich habe den
gerne zugestimmt im haushaltsausschuss
dass wir das gemeinsam auf den weg
bringen konnten am dienstag am dienstag
hat erinnern uns alle der israelische
staatspräsident in einer denkwürdigen
und bewegenden rede hier im hause dazu
aufgerufen die partnerschaft zwischen
deutschland und israel weiter zu
vertiefen diese partnerschaft wird in
anbetracht der geschichte wie wir
niemals vergessen dürfen und werden
liebe kolleginnen kollegen immer eine
besondere seien niemals liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen darf das
gedenken daran aufhören aber
leider leider des antisemitismus immer
noch ein thema die anzahl
antisemitischer straftaten in
deutschland hat sich nach aktuellen
zahlen
2021 um 29 prozent gegenüber dem vorjahr
auf über 3000 delikte erhöht ich bleibe
dabei was ich bereits bei den
haushaltsberatungen für dieses jahr
formuliert hatte wir dürfen nie
nachlassen
antisemitismus in diesem land mit aller
konsequenz zu bekämpfen so lange in
irgend eine jüdische einrichtung in
diesem land unter polizeischutz stehen
muss liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen
und deswegen halten richtig und
notwendig dass wir weiter in dem
haushalt einen besonderen schwerpunkt
auf dieses wichtige thema legen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die einzelplan
beratung werden schwierig in diesem jahr
wären mehrfach darüber gesprochen
wir wollen und wir werden als koalition
die schuldenbremse einhalten sie ist
nicht nur vorgaben der verfassung sie
dämpft inflation und sie schützt
nachfolgende generationen vor
übermäßigen schulden
deutschland muss in finanzpolitischer
hinsicht
stabilitätsanker in der europäischen
union bleiben und nicht zu vergessen in
zeiten von krise ist haushaltspolitisch
solidität auch die sicherstellung von
handlungs spieler auch mit der zukunft
viel liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
im innenpolitischen bereich in den
kernbereichen der inneren sicherheit ist
schon angesprochen worden
cybersicherheit bevölkerungsschutz
spüren wir diese herausforderung
besonders und als haushälter werden wir
uns natürlich diesen entwurf sehr genau
darauf anke und gucken und sehen ob und
wo auch tagesaktuelle noch
handlungsbedarf besteht schon daher
liebe kolleginnen kollegen von der union
greift es völlig zu kurz wenn die der
kollege kiesewetter vor gestern oder
heute der kollege traum von einer
schwächung wichtiger säulen unserer
sicherheitsarchitektur gesprochen wird
oder gar von einem offenbarungseid in
der innen und sicherheitspolitik
im gegenteil es zeugt doch von der
unkenntnis der zahlen deren äpfel mit
birnen verglichen nämlich ein haushalt
mit bauministeriums anteil und einen und
einen ohne wenn bei berücksichtigung bei
berücksichtigung des auslaufens re
konjunkturmittel ist wie schon erwähnt
ein klarer aufwuchs im etat
festzustellen und das ein wichtiges
signal für die innere sicherheit in
diesem land
wie schon angesprochen wird allein im
bereich des bundesamtes für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
146 neue stellen geschaffen wir schlagen
als fdp in umsetzung des
koalitionsvertrages vor dass wir das
verfassungsrechtlich auch endlich
verankern dass das bundesamt zur
zentralstelle wird aber nicht nur dort
setzen wir als koalition schwerpunkte
das bsi erfährt ein enorm mittel auf
wuchs auf über 250 millionen damit die
dringend notwendige stärkung des bsi
erfolgen kann und dort insbesondere sind
die mittel zur bekämpfung von
cyberkriminalität und zur abwehr von
cyberangriffen hinterlegt auch im
bereich der it und netzpolitik
verdoppeln der unter berücksichtigung
von sondereffekten fasst die mittel an
setze starke zeichen
starkes zeichen der handlungsfähigkeit
dieser koalition in schwierigen zeiten
deswegen sind wir gespannt als koalition
welche konkreten vorschläge von ihrer
seite in der beratung kommen werden ich
freue mich jedenfalls drauf der
entspannende beratung liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen vielen dank
er sagt thorsten lieb für die fdp
fraktionen und auch wenn mit diesem
haushaltsgesetz bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner die schuldenbremse
jahr nach drei jahren wieder einhalten
will hat er in dieser woche doch in
einem interview mit der süddeutschen
zeitung beispielsweise gesagt dass er
eine erneute aussetzung der
schuldenbremse in einer notsituation
nicht ausschließe dies nur noch mal weil
es eben angesprochen wurde andré hahn
jetzt führen linken klimawandel und
energiekrise all das hat auch folgen für
die zuständigkeiten des
bundesministeriums des innern und für
heimat sowie für den sport auch wenn der
name leider noch immer nicht im
ministerium im namen enthalten ist und
steht der vorliegende haushaltsentwurf
wird der sich daraus ergebenden
verantwortung aus meiner sicht leider
nicht in allen bereichen gerecht das
beginnt beim schutz der bevölkerung vor
zivilen katastrophen und geht hin eben
bis zum sport frau ministerin ich kann
ja ihre begeisterung für unsere
fußball-nationalmannschaft der frauen
durchaus verstehen aber muss man deshalb
gleich drei mal binnen weniger tage auf
kosten der steuerzahler zu spielen
unseres teams während
europameisterschaft nach london fliegen
müssen wir und hier meine ich den bund
das land bayern und die stadt münchen
die vor wenigen tagen stattgefunden
durchaus beeindruckenden european
championships mit rund 100 millionen
euro unterstützen und muss der bund die
fußball-europameisterschaft 2024 der
uefa mit einem zweistelligen
millionenbetrag fördern das alles das
alles wird die zustimmung der
bevölkerung für weitere olympia
bewerbungen in deutschland kaum
befördern das gilt im übrigen auch für
das militär sportfest invictus games für
die im verteidigungsministerium
35 millionen eingeplant sind
gleichzeitig und darauf kommt es an frau
ministerin warten die 90.000
sportvereine die für den schul- sport-
und schwimmunterricht verantwortlichen
die betreiber von fitnessstudios oder
gesundheitssport einrichtungen bislang
vergeblich auf jede unterstützung um zu
verhindern dass angesichts der
energieknappheit und der schon jetzt
spürbare preissteigerungen
nicht wieder schwimmbäder und
sportstätten geschlossen werden wie
schon in der korona pandemie fakt ist in
den drei entlastungs päckchen der
bundesregierung kommt der sport wieder
einmal nicht vor wo waren sie eigentlich
in diesen verhandlungen frau ministerin
fehlern
die vor sechs jahren von der
bundesregierung und die usb beschlossene
spitzensport reform erweist sich
zunehmend als gescheitert statt endlich
dem sanierungsstau bei den sportstätten
und schwimmbädern mit einem überfälligen
vierten goldenen plan sport zu begegnen
wollen sie die schon jetzt viel zu
niedrigen förderprogramme des bundes
finanzieren sprich zukünftig kürzen
dafür sind sie frau feser gemeinsam mit
der bundesbauministerium verantwortlich
für die linke ist dass der eindeutig
falsche weg
zu kritisieren sind zudem weitere
kürzungen im innenministerium bei uns
leben aktuell circa drei millionen
geflüchtete geflüchtete auch aus der
ukraine
und dennoch soll bei den
integrationskursen
71 millionen euro eingespart und bei der
migrationsberatung 16 millionen euro
abgezogen werden das bundes
aufnahmeprogramm für aus politischen
gründen verfolgte oder auch von
ehemaligen ortskräfte aus afghanistan
steht in den sternen und es nicht
ausfinanziert
meine damen und herren der schutz
unserer bevölkerung hat nun endlich die
priorität die er schon längst hätte
haben müssen das waren ihre großen worte
fräser als sie zum jahrestag der
flutkatastrophe im urteil vom juli von
einem neustart sprachen im
haushaltsentwurf ist davon nicht viel zu
sehen ganz im gegenteil sie ziehen
gelder beim technischen hilfswerk und
beim bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz
und katastrophenhilfe abstatt im etat
aufzustocken vor allem bei den
ehrenamtlich tätigen setzen sie den
rotstift an dass es völlig inakzeptabel
und wenn hierzulande gerade waldbrände
zum teil wochenlang wüten auch bei mir
im nationalpark sächsische schweiz
kürzen sie ausgerechnet gelder bei den
wasserwirtschaftlichen
vorsorgemaßnahmen bei dem es auch um
löschwasser geht das ist absurd
die feuerwehren und die weiteren
einsatzkräfte verdienen unser aller dank
aber eben auch unsere unterstützung die
realität sieht leider anders aus
löschhubschrauber fehlen löschflugzeuge
wollen sie gar nicht beschaffen 100
milliarden für die rüstung machen sie
dagegen weniger wähler innen binnen
weniger wochen locker diese politik geht
an die absolut falsche richtung
stattdessen stattdessen wollen sie nicht
nur immer mehr personal beim
verfassungsschutz sondern vor allem beim
bundeskriminalamt und der bundespolizei
obwohl dort sage und schreibe derzeit
fast 10.000 stellen unbesetzt sind aber
immer noch mehr stellen die sie gar
nicht besetzen können auch das können
wir nicht unterstützen und abschließend
noch ein satz zum öffentlichen dienst
zig tausend beschäftigte arbeiten hier
in der unteren und mittleren bereich
und gehaltsgruppen und spüren schon
jetzt die
preisentwicklungen die sie haben der
aktuelle tarifvertrag endet dieses jahr
am 31 12 in ihrem haushalt gibt es keine
vorsorge für die absehbaren
tariferhöhung die wir unterstützen auch
das wäre ihre verantwortung gewesen dort
entsprechend geld einzustellen
herzlichen dank
andré hahn war das für seine fraktion
unter anderem sprecher für sport und
auch sprecher für zivilen
katastrophenschutz das feld alles unter
den bereich des innenministeriums und er
hat ja beispielsweise angesprochen die
sportförderung die wird im
haushaltsentwurf in diesem einzelplan
für das innenministerium dass der
entwurf angeht zumindest auch gekürzt
liebe frau ministerin nancy faeser die
folgen des russischen angriffskriegs auf
die ukraine die korona pandemie und die
auswirkungen des klimawandels ja das
sind schon riesengroße herausforderung
keine leichte aufgabe unter einhaltung
der schuldenbremse ein haushaltsentwurf
für das jahr 23 aufzustellen und das
gilt insbesondere für die innenpolitik
den sicherheit integration zusammenhalt
digitalisierung politische bildung und
auch der sport sind wichtiger denn je
ich verstehe ja es ist aufgabe der
opposition sachverhalte zuzuspitzen zu
übertreiben zu dramatisieren aber ich
finde angesichts der multiplen krisen
die uns zu schaffen machen darf man in
politischen debatten schon ein wenig
mehr redlichkeit erwarten gerade in
diesen schwierigen zeiten
es ist finde ich auch für eine
opposition nicht zu viel verlangt etwas
mehr zu differenzieren und genauer
hinzusehen anstatt nur zwei zahlen
miteinander zu vergleichen diesen
anspruch habe ich vor allem das muss ich
ehrlich sagen schon auch an unserer
früheren koalitionspartner die cdu csu
einerseits heißt es da nämlich immer die
schuldenbremse müsse eingehalten werden
andererseits wird bei jedem bereich
insbesondere der innenpolitik kritisiert
dass der haushaltsansatz ja viel zu
niedrig sei das passt finde ich schon
mal überhaupt gar nicht zusammen dann
wird landauf landab über angeblich
analyse kürzungen im etat der
bundesinnenministerium hergezogen
verschwiegen wird dass der baubereich in
ein neues ministerium überführt wurde
verschwiegen wird auch dass mit den
konjunkturpaketen
wir ja ganz bewusst investitionen in die
innere sicherheit vorgezogen haben und
das in einer erheblichen somit zwei
milliarden euro von vornherein war doch
dass diese zusätzlichen sondermittel
zeitlich befristet sind und nun wie
geplant auch zum jahresende auslaufen
keine überraschung und erst recht keine
katastrophe und kein skandal vielmehr
muss man doch sagen gut dass wir es
gemacht haben denn wenn man sich
anschaut was wir jetzt zur verfügung
haben dann sind wir doch froh dass wir
beispielsweise 700 millionen euro bei
der bundespolizei vorab investiert haben
dass wir bei der bundespolizei neue
schiffe haben in der ostsee wie ich mit
der kollegin bettina hagedorn neulich in
neustadt in ostholstein
betrachten konnte und das ist wichtig in
anbetracht der neuen lage in der ostsee
wenn ich daran denke dass das thw in den
letzten zweieinhalb jahren
zweieinhalbtausend neufahrzeuge für die
668 ortsverbände erhalten hat da muss
ich sagen zum glück haben wir das
vorgezogen denn sonst hätten wir diese
fahrzeuge gar nicht gehabt bei den
großen krisen lagen in den letzten paar
monaten und das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenschutz hat auch über
sondermittel in höhe von 300 millionen
euro
profitiert beispielsweise für den
beschaffung von modernen sirenen um den
ländern zu helfen weil diese ja ihre
eigentlichen aufgabe nicht nachkommen
und da finde ich es schon ziemlich
unverfroren herzliche grüße nach
stuttgart und düsseldorf wenn die
dortigen landesinnenminister jetzt den
bund kritisieren dass wir das nicht
dauerhaft machen sondern diese hohen
sondermittel jetzt wie geplant etwas
zurückführen ich bin der meinung darüber
müssen wir reden jedenfalls glaube ich
dass der haushaltsentwurf in ordnung ist
er ist gut der gute arbeitsgrundlage
es sind gute dinge drin im vergleich zur
finanzplanung gibt es auch einen halb
milliarden euro zusätzlich die
bundespolizei plus 1000 zusätzliche
stellen das bka plus 180 das bbk 146
also ich kann die liste noch weit und
lange fortsetzen
vieles gutes ist drin selbstverständlich
ist der haushaltsentwurf nicht perfekt
hier und da merkt man schon die decke
ist knapp vielleicht viel zu knapp aber
dafür gibt es ja uns haushälter und ich
freue mich auf die beratungen im
nächsten paar wochen insbesondere
mitspieler schäfer und mit thorsten
liebt das hat ja letztes mal ganz
hervorragend geklappt wenn wir uns
anschauen wie viel wir umgeschichtet und
nochmal zusätzlich mobilisiert haben
jedenfalls freue ich mich auf die
diskussion ich bin mir sicher dass wir
diesen haushaltsentwurf schon noch mal
ein ganzes stück besser machen können
aus gutem kann man immer noch was
besseres machen das ist das motto für
den einzelplan 06 in der nächsten woche
herzlichen dank und
sagt hier martin gerster für die
sozialdemokraten
und jetzt werden wir hierzu diesem
einzelplan eine weitere rednerin aus den
reihen der cdu csu fraktion das wird
sein die abgeordnete mechthilde wittmann
dieses mitglied im innenausschuss
bundesministerin kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie mich eines verdammt
stellen weil ich glaube dass es wichtig
ist wenn wir über die zahlen die ich
jetzt dann gleich anfangen werde reden
selbstverständlicher dr lieb hat die
unionsfraktion das bauministerium in
sämtlichen betrachtungen herausgerechnet
dr liebe ich kann ihnen da nur eine
sagen diese behauptung die sie vor
aufgestellten in der hoffnung zu retten
was hier in diesem haushalt eben noch
gerettet werden muss ist schlicht
unseriös uns erinnert mich an das
unseriöse verhalten ihres
finanzministers bei dem entglitten
haushalt 2023
meine damen und herren
frau bundesministerin phaser sie haben
vor drei tagen beim empfang der
sicherheitsbehörden gesagt sicherheit
kostet das sind wir vollkommen an ihrer
seite
und sie haben jetzt gesagt sicherheit
ist nicht selbstverständlich und auch da
sind wir an ihrer seite und ich sehe
hier bestreben etwas zu tun was auch von
uns mitgetragen wird nämlich in
irgendeiner form auch haushaltsdisziplin
zu wahren seriösität macht sich auch
daran fest und es ist bedauerlich genug
dass sowohl die kollegin schäfer als
auch der kollege gerster von sich aus
gesagt haben welche nachbesserungsbedarf
denn der haushalt des innenministeriums
noch hat ich habe das gefühl sie werden
im stich gelassen von ihren eigenen
leuten nicht nur von den fdp ministern
buschmann und
lindner
tatsächlich ist es so dass dieser
haushalt natürlich und 2,2 milliarden
euro gekürzt wird und tatsächlich ist es
so dass mammut aufgaben vor uns stehen
nicht nur im bereich der migration und
integration sondern ganz vor allem in
der sicherheit für unsere bürgerinnen
und bürger unseres bürgerinnen und
bürger fühlen sich unsicher vor
straftaten und kriminalität das wissen
wir trotz des tatsächlich gestiegenen
sicherheitsstandards bei uns in der
bundesrepublik deutschland aber sie
fühlen sich auch unsicher vor
naturkatastrophen die diese zeit bringt
und von vielen dingen mit denen sie
nicht gerechnet haben lassen sie mich
zum ersten bereich kommen wir hatten im
jahr 2015 1 5 millionen flüchtlinge die
zu uns kommen im jahr 2022 verzeichnen
wir jetzt schon eine million flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine und ein weiteren anstieg
aus anderen ländern insgesamt knapp drei
millionen flüchtlinge im land und
dennoch kürzen sie ihn so wichtigen
bereich der integrationskurse um mehr
als 70 millionen und sie kürzen in
migrationsberatung ebenfalls noch mal um
13 millionen meine damen und herren
allein der bayerische haus bald hat ein
höheres volumen im bereich migration und
integration als der bundeshaushalt und
200 millionen höher als der
bundeshaushalt das zeigt die pedale für
die wir haben aber stattdessen stecken
sie 20 millionen neuen behörden
unabhängige asylverfahrens beratung die
ergebnisse sehen wir verzweifelt vor ort
die so etwas bringt und wissen sie wo
sie noch kürzen was noch gar nicht
erwähnt wurde im bereich der leistungen
im rahmen der humanitären aufnahme mit
für die sich diese bundesregierung so
gerne rühmt kürze sie um 60 prozent um
60 prozent ich kann sie nicht verstehen
da chancen aufenthaltsrecht dass sie so
rühmen hat ein mittelbedarf von über 70
millionen euro kein einziger euro ist in
ihrem haushalt dafür aufgewiesen kein
einziger und lassen sie mich vielleicht
rein inhaltlich noch mal etwas sagen
wenn wir menschen die 15 jahre da sind
darin stützen wollen dass sie eventuell
jetzt mal anfangen ihre identität zu
klären dann glaube ich geht hier etwas
vollkommen in die falsche richtung dafür
hatten sie zeit in fünf jahren lassen
sie mich weitergehen zum thema des
extremismus ja am rechtsextremismus
bringen sie kein blatt zwischen uns wir
werden mit ihnen fest an der seite
stehen dass wir diesen massiv bekämpfen
aber wieder einmal lassen sie auch in
diesem haushalt das auge blind vor den
gefahren des linksextremismus und ich
sage es ihnen noch mal wie schon die
letzten male der linksextremismus
richtet sich gegen die staatliche
ordnung und ihre vollzugsorgane und
dagegen in erster linie gegen unsere
polizistinnen und polizisten die nichts
davon haben wenn wir sie da nicht
stützen selbst wenn sie es sagen sie
menschen
und der stellenaufbau bundespolizei und
bundeskriminalamt ist richtig das sind
während wir das seite aber was hilft es
den polizisten wenn eine halbe milliarde
euro bei der ausrüstung fehlt sie können
sie doch nicht blank gehen lassen zu
einer teilweise hohen bedrohungslage sie
lassen sie im stich wenn sie sie nicht
ausreichen ausrüsten und auch keira kiss
ist dieser haushalt seine fehler
sie sprechen vom bevölkerungsschutz und
sie sagen auch hier würden wir
entsprechend stützen schon vor schäfer
hat gesagt das hier erheblicher
nachholbedarf ist und dass klinke daher
so zynisch wenn sie mir sagen dass
dieses alles ein ich habe den zuruf aus
der fdp gehört selbstzweck werde sagen
sie mal wo leben sie eigentlich es ist
nicht selbstzweck unsere bevölkerung zu
schützen es ist nicht selbstzweck im
katastrophenfall zu helfen und deswegen
kann es nicht sein dass wir hier in
diesem maße kürzen 30 prozent beim thw
40 prozent beim bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
nur dass wir jetzt noch mal erinnern
dieses wurde einstmals von rot-grün
aufgelöst und musste unter der
unionsführung wieder entsprechend
aufgebaut werden und das ist uns
gelungen und
lassen sie mir hier noch einmal ein
ganzes stück weiter gehen sie wollen das
ehrenamt stützen das ist unser aller
aller bedürfnis das wollen wir und
gleichzeitig streifen sie beim ehrenamt
allein beim bbk eine viertelmillion und
ähnlich sieht es aus beim thw denn dort
haben sie von 7,6 millionen auf
0,6 millionen gestrichen wenn es um das
ehrenamt geht das ist ein schlag ins
gesicht all jener die wir brauchen das
sie uns vor ort helfen all jene wie
zuerst da sein wenn die katastrophe
passiert und die unsere gesamte
unterstützung brauchen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren dieser
haushalt hat frau schäfer ich kann ihnen
nur zustimmen und ihnen herr gerster
auch diese hat erheblichen nachholbedarf
wir sind dann hier der seite bewegen sie
sich setzte sich durch gegen die
kollegen von der fdp vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen lamya kaddor
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dank auch
für die mahnung an der schrecklichen
terror vor 50 jahren in münchen ich
möchte aber noch daran erinnern dass
heute vor 22 jahren bashing scheck von
ms vermessung ermordet worden ist und
erst elf jahre später tatsächlich diese
tat aufgeklärt werden konnte wir
befinden uns in der haushaltsdebatte
begleitet von hoch angespannten und auch
sehr dynamischen entwicklungen und ich
sagte sie bereiten also übrigens wie
schon zur krone krise den boden für
extremistische bestrebungen akteurinnen
nutzen diese für das hehre mittel des
protests und ich sage es ganz deutlich
solche unerwarteten proteste sind zu
einem booster der extremen rechten
geworden der nicht unterschätzt und vor
allem nicht an spaziergang oder freie
meinungsäußerung bisher zum teil gab
gehört haben verharmlost werden nach als
staat ist es unsere aufgabe machen sie
jetzt als staat ist es unsere aufgabe
dieses unterlaufen berechtigter protest
anliegen besonders im blick zu behalten
liebe frau bundesinnenministerium vor
zwölf monaten haben wir die
bundestagswahl gewonnen und vor zehn
monaten hat diese koalition ihre arbeit
aufgenommen seitdem behaupten böse
zungen wäre wenig bis nichts passiert in
der innenpolitik und herr seehofers
geist würde durch die flure des
bundesinnenministeriums um arbeit das
ist so nicht richtig ich war ja des
öfteren dar die grünen stehen bereit wir
haben einen an beziehungen
koalitionsvertrag um eine liberale
humane und den sicherheitsinteressen
unseres landes entsprechend zielgenau
politik anzugehen sei es beim
staatsbürgerschaftsrecht bei der
konkretisierung des aktionsplans gegen
rechts oder die demokratie fördergesetz
genauso wie bei der novellierung des
bundespolizeigesetzes wir setzen auf
prävention gegen jeglichen extremismus
auch auf den islamismus übrigens ja auch
dem liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der opposition doch wer wie ich gegen
islamismus kämpft der muss in der regel
auch und er weiß auch islamfeindlichkeit
ist die an der seite dieser medaille der
einzelplan 06 bei dem wir hier sprechen
hat die meisten kürzungen zu verzeichnen
aber an prävention dürfen wir nicht
sparen sehr geehrte damen und herren
im sommer reichen euskirchen allein dort
starben 26 menschen bei der schlimmsten
hochwasserkatastrophe seit langem 182
personen insgesamt was sollen wir den
menschen vor ort sagen wenn die warnung
gegen hochwasser oder stromausfall das
nächste mal wieder nicht oder zu spät
ankommen sollten das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz soll eine
steuerungsfunktion haben und dass wir
dafür geld in den haushalt einstellen
war eine verabredung doch blicke ich in
den aktuellen haushaltsentwurf das muss
ich kritisch anmerken kann ich das nicht
finden da müssen wir gemeinsame wege
finden hier zu einem aufwuchs zu kommen
aber auch andere bedrohungsszenarien
müssen rechtzeitig erfasst werden können
ich werde mir heute das gemeinsame
terrorabwehrzentrum mit raptor anschauen
ich bin überzeugt dass die beamtinnen
beamte dort hervorragende arbeit leisten
nur ihr auftraggeber geht's abgekürzt
ist formal keine eigenständige behörde
sondern nur eine kooperationsplattform
der mit der terrorismus-bekämpfung
befassten bundes und landesbehörden die
unter faktischer führung des bks für
eine verbesserte koordinierung und damit
für kontrolle sorgen soll seit jahren
wissen wir aber dass sie von otto schily
im jahre 2004 als behelfslösung
eingeführte stelle endlich eine
rechtsgrundlage braucht schon allein zur
abgrenzung zwischen polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden ich erinnere sie
auch hier gerne in unserem
koalitionsvertrag
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
erleben eine verdichtung und
gleichzeitigkeit der krisen migrations
krise klimakrise corona krise
energiekrise und diese koalition muss
alles dafür tun und diesen zusammenhalt
und die sicherheit in unserem land
weiterhin zu gewährleisten
wenn eine militärmacht die russland
irgendein land mitten in europa
überfällt insider andere vor
ausländischer dienste normalität sind
wenn stress tests gefahren werden müssen
der gaspreis explodiert wird der
politische um monetäre handlungsraum
spielraum eng wir stehen hier aber im
board der bürgerinnen bürger gegenüber
für ihre innere sicherheit und auch
äußere sicherheit weiterhin zu sorgen
der zusammenhang zwischen colon
außenpolitik und klugen politik war
immer schon groß er war von euch nie
größer als heute deshalb lassen sie uns
mit verstand herzblut und großem mut in
diesem winter gehen und auch um diese
haushaltsverhandlungen fehlen
das hat die sprecherin für inneres und
heimat der
grünen jetzt können wir markus möhl für
die afd
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich möchte meine rede mit einem
großen dankeschön beginnen unser dank
gilt den feuerwehren dem thw der
bundeswehr der bundespolizei und aller
weiteren kräfte bei der bekämpfung
zahlreicher waldbrände diesen sommer zb
in sachsen oder in berlin die
einsatzkräfte zeigen vollen einsatz und
geben ihr bestes vielen dank dafür
und jetzt komme ich zum unerfreulichen
teil dem haushaltsentwurf der links
gelben bundesregierung wehren durch die
explodierenden energiepreise milliarden
an steuergeldern zusätzlich in die
staatskassen gespült werden und die
vereinnahmung steuern unter anderem
dafür verwendet werden sollen um für
andere länder die folgen des ukraine
kriegs abzumildern will links gelb an
der sicherheit der eigenen bürger sparen
zu erhalten das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
112 millionen euro und das technische
hilfswerk
158 millionen euro weniger im
haushaltsentwurf für 2023 und das vor
dem hintergrund der vielen brandeinsätze
in diesem jahr entsetzen und völliges
unverständnis so kommentiert der
deutsche feuerwehrverband die
zugeschriebenen mittel frau ministerin
das kann ja wohl alles nicht wahr sein
aber nicht mit uns die sicherheit
unserer bürger hat für uns oberste
priorität
sparpotenziale sehen wir an ganz anderen
stellen zb bei hunderttausenden
ausreisepflichtigen asylbewerbern und
einer völlig gescheiterten energiewende
aber garantiert nicht beim
bevölkerungsschutz
für die brandbekämpfung brauchen wir
moderne löschen schrauber in
ausreichender anzahl da kann es nicht
angehen dass der bundestag 2009 10 zwar
die beschaffung neuer
transporthubschrauber für die
bundespolizei und damit den ersatz der
circa 40 jahre alten maschinen
beschlossen hat aber nach drei jahren
noch nicht mal die auftragsvergabe
erfolgt ist und noch immer funktioniert
hat digital funken einsatzlagen an
vielen stellen nicht störungsfrei die
einsatzkräfte in tunneln oder
funktionsgebäude wissen was ich meine
vor und bei vor ort besuchen habe ich
mir von der situation ein ausführliches
bild machen können so wie wir unsere
einsatz und rettungskräfte optimal
ausstatten müssen so gilt es auch opfer
von katastrophen schnell und
unbürokratisch zu helfen das versagen
vieler politisch verantwortlicher
während der flutkatastrophe bar tal hat
schon fassungslos gemacht dass von den
versprochenen hilfsgelder nach
inzwischen über einem jahr bisher nur
ein bruchteil ausgezahlt wurde reiht
sich in diese kette ein die betroffenen
brauchen jetzt ihre hilfen ausgezahlt
stadt gelegentlich vorbeischauende
politiker ihrer parteien die betroffenen
gucken und ein paar beschwichtigende
worte da lassen
ich sehe gerade die ministerin ist gar
nicht im rat jetzt kommt sie wieder das
ist schade vielleicht können sie sich so
nachträglich im fernsehen angucken
werden sehr schön würde mich freuen
abschließend die ohnehin schon desolat
sicherheitslage in unserem land wird
durch den links gelben haushaltsentwurf
nochmals verschlechtert während für
links grüne ideologie projekte übrig
steuergeld angefasst wird kreist an
sicherheitsrelevanten stellen der
rotstift wichtige projekte wie bei der
bundespolizei und den dringend
benötigten transporthubschraubern kommen
nicht voran mit unseren
änderungsanträgen werden wie der
regierungskoalition truppen machen denn
für uns gilt unser land zuerst vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
manuel höferlin und erst der
innenpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren
die herausforderungen sind groß von
katastrophen über extremismus im inneren
bei analogen bei digitalen ich glaube
selten stand die innere verfasstheit
unseres landes die freiheit unter
größerem druck und sie ist nicht gut
vorbereitet durch das 16 jahre geführte
unions geführte ministerium
das ist so dass der haushalt aber auch
zeigt dass unter den schwierigen
voraussetzungen unter dem druck den wir
haben den jetzigen veränderten
situationen den herausforderungen
kraftvoll begegnen können und der
entwurf zeigt auch dass wir die
sicherheit der menschen und ihre
freiheit gleichermaßen gewährleisten
können und das obwohl die zeiten
schwieriger sind obwohl vermieter auf
die steuergelder schauen müssen als das
in den letzten 16 jahren der fall war
anderen thermen
wir
haben verschiedene punkte ich kann in
der kürze der zeit nur wenige hervor
kraus greifen deshalb möchte ich sagen
die fortschritts koalition tut sehr viel
mehr für die cybersicherheit die
cybersicherheit ist ein gebiet in dem
die das stark vernachlässigt wurde in
den letzten jahren das obwohl die
betriebslage ständig stieg an vielen
punkten der staat selbst nicht für
sicherheit im cyber raum gesucht hat
gesorgt hat und deshalb investieren wir
in ein echtes schwachstellenmanagement
wir wollen dass sicherheitslücken
geschlossen werden denn wenn etwas die
letzten wochen und monate gezeigt hat
bei vielen vorfällen das ist dass die
sicherheit durch schwachstellen und
damit auch die gesellschaft die
unternehmen extrem gefährdet sind und
deswegen investieren wir in die digitale
infrastruktur des bks und die
zusätzliche ausstattung auch der
bundespolizei denn der staat muss dort
mehr investieren und herren
auch das bsi als zentralstelle für die
cyber sicherheit haben wir vereinbart
das werden wir auch vorantreiben denn es
kann nicht sein dass cyber sicherheit
nicht koordiniert vorangetrieben wird
deswegen soll das bsi als zentrale
stelle agieren in die cyber sicherheit
zusammen dann auch mit den ländern
koordiniert werden kann wir werden dafür
sorgen dass der staat trotzdem
eingriffsbefugnisse hat die vorhanden
sind und sie effektiv anwenden kann denn
es geht im gegensatz zu früher nicht
immer darum mehr und mehr befugnisse auf
den weg zu bringen sondern es geht darum
diese effektiv einzusetzen und dafür
steht diese koalition lassen sie mich
noch kurz ein wort zum
bevölkerungsschutz sagen dieser haushalt
zeigt dass wir im bevölkerungsschutz
mehr investieren denn in zum beispiel
erhält das thw deutlich mehr geld für 30
prozent mehr als 2009 10 dazwischen das
hat herr gerster ausgeführt gab es
sonder sondereffekte und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir beim katastrophenschutz
vorangehen und das geht eben nicht wie
in der vergangenheit immer darum mehr
geld drauf zu schützen wie sie das immer
bei der union machen sondern strukturen
anzupacken und das unterscheidet diese
koalition von ihnen man kann nicht alles
in der politik mit geld zuschütten und
warten bis die zeit vorüber ist sondern
muss dinge ändern und das ist die
strukturreformen katastrophenschutz im
zivilschutz der kollegin sagte gerade
eben so schön hier minister seehofer hat
am ende seiner legislatur zeit entdeckt
acht da gibt es ja das bbk und er wusste
gar nicht so recht was damit sollen soll
hätte man vielleicht mal etwas mehr
früher struktur angefasst dann wären wir
auch heute weiter und die menschen
erwarten dass bei uns und nicht immer
nur mit dem geld umzuwerfen herzlich
danken
manuel höferlin war das der
innenpolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion und ihm folgt es hier für
die sozialdemokraten
elisabeth kaiser
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin
sehr geehrte bürgerinnen und bürger
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
andauernd in krisen haben bei den
menschen spuren hinterlassen und sorgen
weiterhin auch für verunsicherung bis
hin zu ängsten und das wissen wir als
sozialdemokraten den sozialdemokraten
sehr genau steuern dagegen mit
umfassenden hilfen für bürgerinnen und
bürgern und für unternehmen drei
entlastungs paket mit einem volumen von
95 milliarden euro das sind eine klare
botschaft wir erhalten als koalition was
wir versprechen gleichwohl ist es nötig
in solchen zeiten auch diskussions räume
zu haben und es ist gut wenn am sonntag
in thüringen ein breites demokratisches
bündnis von gewerkschaften
betriebsräten kirchen und
jugendverbänden in erfurt deutschen
ortschaft es beunruhigt mich aber wie
rechtsextremisten die sorgen der
menschen ausnutzen sie hetzen und
versuchen unsere gesellschaft zu spalten
das zeigt sich auch in den zunehmenden
hassbotschaften und falschinformationen
verschwörungs erzählungen angriffen auf
die polizei bis hin zu rechts
terroristischen anschlags plänen und das
ist mit ein grund dafür wieso wir die
finanzmittel der sicherheitsbehörden im
haushalt des bundes in das des
bundesinnenministeriums in den
vergangenen jahren kontinuierlich
aufgestockt hat im haushaltsentwurf für
20 23 liegen sie bei insgesamt 5,6
milliarden euro und das ist ein plus von
über 850 millionen euro gegenüber dem
budget aus vor corona zeiten und
sogleich schaffen wir insgesamt 1300
neue stellen für die bundespolizei
bundeskriminalamt und das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
um den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
zu fördern
da freut es mich besonders dass die
bundeszentrale für politische bildung in
den vergangenen haushaltsjahren massiv
ausgebaut wurde und um einen dritten
standort in meiner heimatstadt gera
gewachsen ist und damit sich dieser
trend fortsetzt sondern die
personalmittel auf mehr als 23 millionen
euro steigen und der gesamtansatz für
die bundeszentrale liegt im jahr 2023
mit 87,8 millionen euro um ein drittel
über dem budget von 54 jahren und so
wird die rolle der bpp als kompetenter
träger von bildungsprojekten gerade auch
im rahmen des aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus noch einmal
untermauert
gleichwohl ist es wichtig dass die
förderung für bereits laufende projekte
im zuge des kabinettsbeschlusses gegen
rechtsextremismus und rassismus auf
bisherigem niveau fortgeführt werden
können denn nur zusammen sind wir stark
für unsere demokratie die bewährte
arbeit der bpp ihre kooperationen
initiativen mit vereinen erzeugen
wertvolle synergieeffekte auch mit dem
bundesprogramm demokratie neben das an
anderer stelle im haushalt auch
aufgestockt wird und somit unterstützen
wäre es so übergreifend
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement
in china im hauptamt zur helferinnen und
helfern lebt auch das technische
hilfswerk das thw ist die tragende säule
im bundesweiten zivilen
katastrophenschutz und als
vorstandsmitglied der thw dann bis
helfervereinigung sachsen thüringen da
bin ich auch dankbar für die massiven
investitionen der letzten jahre auch aus
dem nun endenden
konjunkturprogramm bewohner hören die
anschaffung von 1000 neuen fahrzeuge es
macht deutlich dass der
katastrophenschutz für die
bundesregierung höchste priorität hat
das hat die bundesinnenminister noch
einmal sehr deutlich gemacht ich denke
das ist auch ein wichtiges signal hat
die helferinnen und helfer und kameraden
nach kamera
und es zeigt sich auch im betrieb und 49
thw logistikzentren unter anderem auch
im altenburger land aber auch den
investitionen in die ortsverbände und
ist schön zu sehen dass nach langem
warten der neubau und lehrer nun auch
zum einen ende prozent realisiert wird
und da ich vorher wissen wir dass diese
bausteine nur an einem gesamt ensemble
wirken können daher schließen müssen wir
sicherstellen dass die selbst
bewirtschaftungs mittel der ortsverbände
und die ausbildung unserer heldinnen und
helden in zivil und katastrophenschutz
vollumfänglich abgesichert werden daran
müssen wir arbeiten aber da habe ich
sehr großes vertrauen in unseren
haushälter martin gerster und die
kolleginnen und kollegen ich danke ihnen
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
stefan mair
[Applaus]
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
verehrte frau ministerin sie haben in
den mittelpunkt ihrer rede den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt gestellt
ich glaube das ist richtig und im
bereich des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhaltes spielt natürlich der
sport eine ganz entscheidende rolle und
im bereich des sports gab es in den
vergangenen wochen aus meiner sicht zwei
erfreuliche ereignis sind das eine
ereignis haben die kolleginnen die
kollegin schäfer und der kollege dr lieb
bereits erwähnt die aus meiner sicht
sehr erfreuliche einigung der
bundesregierung des freistaats bayern
der landeshauptstadt münchen mit den
opferfamilien des islamistischen
terroranschlags vom 5 september 1972 und
auch eine sehr lange gedauert hat es ist
glaube ich und möchte auch betonen wenn
die 28 millionen entschädigungszahlung
in keiner weise das leid der schmerz die
trauer der opfer und insbesondere deren
angehörigen auch tilgen können ist
glaube ich diese einigung doch ein
wichtiges signal und hat aus meiner
sicht den eindruck hatte ich auch im
vergangenen monat bei der
gedenkveranstaltung eine befriedende
wirkung ich möchte auch betonen dass
insbesondere die bayerische
staatsregierung sind sehr konstruktiv
auch diesbezüglich mit sehr engagiert
das zweite sehr erfreuliche ereignis
waren die european championships elf
tage große begeisterung begeisterte ja
friedlich feiernde zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer in münchen aus nah und fern
aus dem inland und aus dem ausland
schönes wetter große erfolge auch der
deutschen sportlerinnen und sportler nur
meine sehr verehrte frau ministerin wenn
wir weiterhin an der spitze in europa
stelle stehen wollen was die leistungen
im spitzensport anbelangt da müssen wir
auch investieren und dann brauchen wir
vor allem auch moderne und zeitgemäße
sportstätten und wenn ich mir jetzt den
haushalt der des bundesinnenministeriums
ansehe dann wird genau das gegenteil
gemacht wir haben laut deutschen
olympischen sportbund in deutschland
einem investitionsstau im bereich der
sportstätten von ungefähr 31
euro in der letzten legislaturperiode
haben wir als cdu csu geführte
bundesregierung vor allem im
bundesinnenministerium den goldenen plan
wieder aufgelegt den investitionspakt
sportstätten mit 370 millionen euro im
letzten jahr und in diesem jahr und
einer ausgabe verpflichtung fürs
kommende jahr noch mal in höhe von 21
121 millionen euro leider haben sie frau
fischer jetzt entschieden dass dieses
programm komplett eingestellt wird und
das ist sage ich ganz offen ein schlag
ins gesicht von 90.000 sportvereinen von
27 millionen sporttrainer sportlern in
deutschland und von 8 millionen
ehrenamtlichen
diese vollbremsung ist absolut
kontraproduktiv
weil natürlich selbst die 370 millionen
euro die jetzt der bund im letzten und
in diesem jahr zur verfügung gestellt
hat noch in keiner weise dazu beitragen
den investitionsstau im bereich von
maroden schwimmhallen von verfallen von
nicht wo der sturm hohen beitrag aber es
war ein wichtiger aspekt und vor dem
hintergrund kann ich sie nur dringend
auffordern diese entscheidung zu
revidieren es gibt große enttäuschung
bei den sportvereinen in deutschland
über diese entscheidung bei den kommunen
und ich kann ihnen eines zu sorgen wir
als cdu csu als die parteien des sports
und des ehrenamtes in deutschland werden
nicht müde werden auf dieses defizit
auch weiterhin zu weisen meine
kolleginnen und kollegen sie haben dann
groß ihren neustart im bereich des
sports gelobt frau ministerin dieses
programm ist vom grundsatz sehr wichtig
nur es ist vollkommen unzureichend
finanziert
sie haben vergessen zu erwähnen dieses
programm ist gerade mal mit 25 millionen
euro
dotiert davon gehen fünf millionen euro
in eine werbekampagne 1,3 millionen euro
verwaltungsausgaben so dass letzten
endes weniger als 20 millionen euro zur
verfügung stehen wenn man dies auf
90.000 sportvereinigung deutschland
unterbricht kommt bei einem sportverein
lorimer 200 euro an dies sorgt als offen
das ist lächerlich das ist vollkommen
unter
meine sehr verehrten kolleginnen und
kollegen wir werden weiterhin als
cdu/csu die parteien seien die sich für
den sport in deutschland stark machen
die auch diese defizite der
bundesregierung hinweisen und vor allem
es auch weiterhin dabei bewenden nicht
bewenden lassen nun darauf hinzuweisen
dass die dass der sport in deutschland
von der jetzigen bundesregierung
stiefmütterlich behandelt wird sondern
wir werden auch weiter da wo wir
entscheidungen mit mir einflüssen können
uns auch aktiv und konstruktiv für den
sport und für die sporttreibenden in
deutschland einsetzen
stephan mayer war das für die cdu csu
fraktion
der einzelplan innen der hier gelesen
wird das ist ja übrigens jetzt zum
abschluss der haushaltsberatungen hier
der letzte einzelplan dann erwarten wir
im weiteren verlauf am mittag lediglich
noch die sogenannte schlussrunde zum
haushaltsgesetz befördern das ganze in
die ausschüsse überwiesen wird marcel
emmerich jetzt für die grünen
der bundeshaushalte entwurf vorliegt er
zeigt eindeutig dass der
regierungskoalition der sport sehr sehr
wichtig ist die ausgaben dafür sind sehr
stabilen und wenn man sich anschaut wie
es um den sport in deutschland steht und
sich anschaut dass über die hälfte der
bevölkerung ist als unsichere
schwimmerinnen und schwimmer gilt und
sich anschaut wie viele zu wenige
schwimmbäder wir in deutschland haben
dann ist das eine gescheiterte
investitionspolitik oder eine
gescheiterte sportpolitik von 16 jahren
unionsgeführte bundesinnenministerium
hier hier hier investiert in den sport
und wir bringen jetzt unter anderem den
einstieg in der safe sportzentrum rein
und das ist wichtig für die
sexualisierte gewalt im sport das zeigen
die vorfälle vorfälle beim schwimm
verband es drängt ist es dringend
notwendig dass wir hier was machen
und egal wo man diese woche hier im
parlament saß ihre redebeiträge hier
hatten einfach nur das buch von cdu im
sinne unseriös und durchdacht und
unglaubwürdig weil man kann nicht auf
der einen seite immer mehr geld fordern
bei allen titeln und auf der anderen
seite dann in der finanzdebatte meckern
und die schuldenbremse nicht im
geringsten anrühren wollen und keine
eigenen alternativen finanzierungs
vorschläge vorlegen das ist einfach
unglaubwürdig
was haben sie denn gemacht in den
letzten 16 jahren bei der ruhegehälter
ruhegehalts fähigkeit für die polizei
ist nichts passiert dass die
it-sicherheit zu marode da steht liegt
in ihrer verantwortung und ihr
ehemaliger minister seehofer wusste
nicht mal für was die abkürzung baby
card überhaupt steht das ist doch die
realität mit der wir zu tun haben und
diesen versäumnissen räumen wir jetzt
auf und holen wir jetzt auch
wir investieren in die cybersicherheit
wir sorgen für eine härtung der
it-infrastruktur und wir sorgen auch
dafür dass rechtsextremismus konsequent
bekämpft wird das sind alles punkte die
uns sehr wichtig sind und dass den
punkte wo wir jetzt auch in den weiteren
haushaltsberatungen auch als fraktion
vielleicht eine ein oder anderen stelle
noch mal stark nach steuern werden und
müssen gerade beim thema
bevölkerungsschutz zum beispiel aber
auch bei den beschäftigten die sich um
die der digitale bekämpfung von taten
etc er kümmern da gibt es in meinen
augen noch großen nachholbedarf auch bei
den integrationskursen aber das ist
glaube ich eine art und weise der
politik die kennen sie gar nicht dass
man sich in einem das beratungsverfahren
noch mal konstruktiv und selbstbewusst
als parlamentarier und
parlamentarierinnen einbringt und so
verstehen wir unsere rolle aber als
koalitionsabgeordnete sehr wohl
und jetzt noch einen satz zu ihnen dir
da drüben am rechten rand ich finde es
beschämend dass sie überhaupt sich zu
dem tod von malte c äußern denn es ist
ihre politik sind ihre störche es sind
ihre es sind ihre sind ihre störche es
sind eindeutig wieder störche die diese
klimafreundliche politik vorantreiben
und diesen hass säen und das ist dann
auch häufig das ergebnis
finden sehr gerne frau ministerin sehr
dankbar und auch den vier beauftragten
der bundesregierung regierung dass sie
sich hier so klar und deutlich geäußert
haben dass jan expertengremium einführen
das sich genau mit dieser bekämpfung von
homophobie und wir freundlichkeit
auseinander setzt das zeigt dass diese
regierung da ein klares zeichen setzt
das ist etwas was der frühere
innenminister bei diesen themen leider
nicht so gemacht hat und das ist da auch
ein ganz großer paradigmenwechsel und
das zeigt einfach dass unsere begriff
von innere sicherheit ein begriff ist er
sagt wir müssen alle menschen beschützen
die sicherheit ist für alle menschen und
das ist egal wen man liebt wo man
herkommt an was man glaubt würde sonst
das ist unser ansatz und so machen wir
unsere politik und so gehen wir auf die
haushaltsberatung an
nächster redner für die afg fraktion
johann könig
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen und vor allem liebe
sportler das parlament hat den sport
haushalt fast verdoppelt seitdem die afd
in den bundestag eingezogen ist
soviel zu dem thema welche partei sich
hier für den sport einsetzt im
kernbereich sind es heute 300 millionen
euro
damit damit wurde der spitzensport aber
gerade mal vor dem zusammenbruch
gerettet inzwischen aber sind die
warnsignale überdeutlich im zweiten jahr
hintereinander wurden zentralen
haushaltstitel etwa 30 millionen euro
nicht verbraucht es gibt also nach
jahrzehnten der vernachlässigung des
spitzensports und des sports gar keine
sportler trainer und strukturen mehr
welche das geld vollständig verbrauchen
können es gab sogar verbände die hatten
mehr hauptamtliche funktionäre als
olympia und perspektivkader es fehlt
also an nachwuchs diese fehlentwicklung
muss gestoppt werden
mehr geld vom bund allein wird das aber
nicht ändern hier sind die bundesländer
gefragt denn sport ist in der hauptsache
ländersache die sport und kultusminister
müssen jetzt die eliteschulen des sports
die sport orientierten schulen und die
kooperation von sportvereinen mit normal
schulen massiv ausbauen
jeder in den sport investiert euro hilft
den jugendlichen in ihrer
persönlichkeitsentwicklung bringt sie
von der straße hilft bei der integration
in die deutsche gesellschaft
und zahlt sich über die bessere
gesundheit mehrfach aus ein system das
menschen nicht zu mehr leistung
motiviert geht garantiert und da wenn
man sich aber die politik von heute
anschaut könnte man meinen dieser
untergang wird billigend in kauf
genommen denn uferloses geld drucken
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen und
sanktionslos hartz4 sind doch der
garantierte weg in dem beispiellosen
untergang ist wir sportfreunde von der
afg während insgesamt sieben
änderungsanträge machen vornehmlich um
die trainer und athleten finanzierung zu
verbessern immer noch gehen in
deutschland beim übergang von schule zur
ausbildung und von der ausbildung zum
beruf viel zu viele talente verloren
sport frei und wir freuen uns auf die
beratungen im sport haushalt
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
philipp harte weg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind im
einzelplan 6 und da sind wir nun mal in
der titelgruppe 2 in erster linie beim
spitzensport angesichts der allgemeinen
haushaltslage haben wir für diesen
bereich natürlich auch nicht
unbegrenzten handlungsspielraum wir
haben aber auch im vergleich zu anderen
bereichen eine solide basis um auf der
grundlage den spitzensport
weiterentwickeln zu können und
spitzensport ist vielseitig und bringt
großen mehrwert für die sportlandschaft
die athletinnen athleten sowie unsere
gesamte gesellschaft und so viele
facetten der sport hat so viele akteure
und partner sind enorm wichtig für
aufhorchen spitzensport vom dsb den
behindertensportverband die
olympiastützpunkte athleten deutschland
fes und et den trainer deutsche
sporthilfe bundespolizei zoll und
bundeswehr bis hin zu den wichtigsten
von allen die sportlerinnen und sportler
und so freue ich mich darauf mit ihnen
mit euch über die zukunft des
spitzensports in deutschland zu sprechen
dazu gehören höchstleistungen
leidenschaft und begeisterung dazu
gehört die integrität des sports vom
kampf gegen doping sexualisierte gewalt
oder spielmanipulationen dazu gehört
aber auch europa oder die welt bei uns
zu gast in deutschland zu haben und wir
können sportgroßveranstaltungen von
sportereignissen wie gerade die
basketball-em wie die kanu-wm in
augsburg oder die open championships in
münchen lassen sich ganze städte
regionen das ganze land begeistert und
deutschland kann sich auch in den
nächsten jahren auf vieles freuen oder
anderem auf die special olympics world
games die hand bei weltmeisterschaften
der frauen und männer die universiade
die entwicklungs games oder die
fußball-wm die fußball-em 2024 der
männer
und ich bin überzeugt davon
uns würde etwas noch größeres in eine
debatte darüber gut tun und das sind
olympische spiele und paralympics in
deutschland
wir können eine große sport bewegung
allein mit dem mehrjährigen
bewerbungsprozess ins rollen bringen
eine vorbildrolle in sachen
nachhaltigkeit einbindung der
bevölkerung stärkung der infrastruktur
und wahrung der menschenrechte einnehmen
und allein mit dem bewerbungsprozess
eine einladung an sportbegeisterte in
der ganzen welt senden die faszination
des sports bei uns hier gemeinsam zu
erleben
ein breiter diskussionsprozess der
allein einige jahre dauert kann der
erste schritt zu großer
gesellschaftlicher akzeptanz sein dabei
können wir auch den erfahrungen oder
euphorie der european championships oder
erfahrungen bislang gescheiterte olympia
bewerbungen aufbauen haben wir den mut
den spitzensport auch dadurch zu stärken
indem er einen weiteren
bewerbungsprozess in deutschland
anstoßen ich freue mich die rippe auf
die debatten darüber auf die debatten
über die zukunft des spitzensports auf
die weiteren haushaltsverhandlungen auf
die rede unseres ausschuss positionen
gleich vielen dank
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
frank ullrich
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen werden
gäste
es stimmt mich noch etwas ganz
besonderes dass ich heute hier im hohen
haus für euch reden darf und ich muss es
wirklich gestehen es ist tatsächlich
auch meine herzfrequenz etwas erhöht
ähnlich wie sie auch im biathlon war
der sport bewegt uns und wir bewegen und
bringen mit 300 millionen euro mehr
bewegung in den sport gegenwärtig
befinden wir uns in einer sehr sehr
schwierigen lage ich glaube das sind wir
uns alle einig und gerade in
krisenzeiten kommt den sport doch auch
eine besondere bedeutung zu
der
sportkonzern ist von respekt und
fördert das gesellschaftliche
miteinander
an dieser stelle möchte ich deutlich
sagen werden den sport stärkt und wer
den sport investiert wird in eine
nachhaltige zukunft investieren jeder
geförderte euro kommt den sport und
unserer gesellschaft und auch der
wirtschaft und auch der gesundheit
zugute der sport ist eine schule fürs
leben gut ausgebildete trainer
übungsleiter pädagogen sind eine
wertvolle stütze in unserem system
jede effektive investition potenziert am
ende den erfolg der gesamten
gesellschaft meine damen und herren ja
ja der bundeshaus ist sportlich wir
gestalten das heute für ein noch
besseres morgen deswegen finde ich es
gut und wichtig dass wir unsere kommunen
bei einer sanierung von sportstätten
unterstützen
476 millionen euro stehen hier zur
verfügung
in diesem zusammenhang möchte ich
unseren haushältern für ihre sportliche
einsatzbereitschaft danken und würde
mich freuen wenn wir perspektivisch noch
eine schippe drauflegen können
die energie krise ist für uns alle sehr
herausfordernd erst letzte woche haben
wir als spd-fraktion ein starkes papier
in dresden beschlossen für uns ist klar
wir wollen den betrieb von sportanlagen
und schwimmbädern möglichst aufrecht
erhalten sport deutschland braucht
klimafreundliche sportstätten staaten
vereine spitzenleistungen aber auch
visionen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie uns gemeinsam mehr mut waren
lassen sie uns gemeinsam
über parteigrenzen hinweg
für olympische und paralympische spiele
vor der eigenen haustür behörden die
bundesregierung
die bundesregierung so können sich
ausdrücklich zu sportgroßveranstaltungen
und dieses bekenntnis findet sich auch
im einzelplan 06 wieder egal ob sommer
oder winter weltmeisterschaft in oberhof
oder european championships in münchen
wo wir alle doch wirklich auch sehr
begeistert waren wir können
sportgroßveranstaltungen sehr geehrte
frau ministerin vielen dank dass sie den
sport zur chefsache gemacht haben und
weiter auch machen wollen für mich ist
der sport eine musikwerke sachen
herzensangelegenheit ich persönlich
dürfte insgesamt zwölf olympischen
spielen teilnehmen und
wenn internationale sport
großveranstaltungen strikt an die
beachtung von un leitprinzipien für
wirtschaft menschenrechte und
nachhaltigkeit geknüpft sind
dann sind sie eine win win situation
kommen
es geht auch um eine flamme zu entzünden
sie uns als gesellschaft auch noch näher
zusammenbringt die bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes möchte nicht
wissen was nicht geht sondern sie
möchten eigentlich wissen was möglich
ist und ich sage in jeder krise steckt
auch eine chance wir sollten sie
gemeinsam nutzen denn zusammen sind wir
stärker
und wenn wir mal wieder groß denken
wollen müssen wir alle im kleinen
beginnen das engagement und das wurde
bereits schon angedeutet von über 90.000
vereinen in deutschland ist unbezahlbar
24 millionen vereinsmitgliedern sind ja
doch etwas geschrumpft auch und
unzählige ehrenamtliche bilden den kitt
in unserer gesellschaft mit dem riester
programm setzen wir im bund ein
wichtiges zeichen hier bin ich unserem
minister sehr dankbar dafür gemeinsam
mit dem dfb und
dem gesundheitsministerium im dezember
zeitnah in bewegungs gestalten
die spitze braucht die beide und die
breite braucht die spitze wir oder wer
erfolgreich sein möchte braucht starke
partner
der dmsb seine spitzenverbände der
deutsche behindertenverband die athleten
deutschland die sportministerkonferenz
der sportausschuss des städtetages und
des sportausschuss des deutschen
bundestages als auch
das bmi
wir alle brennen für den sport und
teilen die gemeinsamkeit sport
deutschland weiter voranzubringen
deswegen gehört aus meiner sicht ähnlich
wie es auch in vielen anderen ländern
erfolgreich praktiziert wird der sport
ins grundgesetz
sehr geehrte damen und herren lassen sie
uns motiviert ins neue jahrzehnt staaten
und motiviert diese gesellschaft mit ums
gestalten ich bedanke mich für eure
aufmerksamkeit
frank ullrich war das für die spd und
das ihm der sport eine
herzensangelegenheit das ist das glaubt
man dem ehemaligen biathleten und unter
anderem goldmedaillengewinner natürlich
zeit heute mal durchgehen ihr puls hat
gezeigt dass sie als leistungssportler
noch an der zeit arbeiten müssen aber zu
ihrer ersten rede hier im deutschen
bundestag gratuliere ich ihnen recht
herzlich
also das war seine erste rede und uns
hat uns auch schon gewundert warum er so
lange reden darf aber das ist hier doch
dann muss im bundestag dass man dort bei
den ersten reden etwas milde walten
lässt und er jedoch dass er deutlich
zwei minuten überziehen konnte für die
nächsten redner gilt das sind nicht mehr
mag heinrich mann für die cdu/csu
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen vor zwei
tagen beim parlamentarischen arm der
reserve der bundeswehr die
verteidigungsministerien in satz geprägt
haushalt sei der test auf eine regierung
nicht nur redet sondern auch handelt aus
ihrem mund entbehrt es nicht einer
gewissen ironie war glaube ich mancher
in ihrem ministerium oder in der ukraine
froh wäre wenn sie wenigstens mal mit
ihm reden würde aber der satz ist ja
richtig
und im resümee müssen wir festhalten
dass auch auf reeser sie diesen test
leider mich bestehen ganz im gegenteil
sie legen ihrem hause mit diesem entwurf
an stellen in zentralen feldern an
integration migration die kürzung in
einer zeit wo die migrations zahlen
dramatisch ansteigen sicherlich ein
falsches signal genauso wie die
auflösung des expertenkreises
politischer islamismus und beim thema
thw hätten einige jetzt glaube ich hier
aus den koalitionsfraktionen mal den
tonfall etwas drosseln sollen denn die
kürzungen beim thw insgesamt fast 160
millionen
kommen ja im wesentlichen an beim
ehrenamt und bei der ausbildung der
ernannten und das ist ja und da besteht
ja auch gegen der ampel keine einigkeit
sondern ist ja so dass schon vernehmen
zu vernehmen ist von zb ortsverbänden
das aus der spd das signal kommt man
hätte ja mehr getan aber der böse
finanzminister habe das ja nicht
zugelassen die einigkeit ist ja groß
aber wenn wir alle der meinung sind
bevölkerung so katastrophenschutz in
diesen zeiten hat oberste priorität dann
erwarten wir glaube ich alle zu recht
dass dann auch die innenministerin zum
finanzminister geht wenn er das nicht
versteht bereits schuldig auftritt und
sagt wir brauchen das geld für das
ehrenamt im bevölkerungsschutz und
frau besser sie haben ja auch viele
richtige ansätze und mit der
cyber-sicherheit agenda haben sie ja
auch wichtige punkte gesetz ist es
richtig unternehmen vor erpresserischen
hackern zu schützen es ist richtig die
kritisch vor dem kollaps zu bewahren
bürger sicher im netz surfen zu lassen
und dann kommt der haushalt und dann
sage ich nicht dass es ambitionslos
sondern schreibt zum beispiel der
tagesspiegel das sei ein ambitionierter
plan im haushalt ist davon wenig zu
sehen oder aber viel agenda wenig
stellen und wenig stellen das bsi siehe
genannt das bsi soll eine zentralstelle
werden deutschlandweit federführend
agieren die abstimmungsprozesse werden
ein ausmaß annehmen dass wahrscheinlich
nicht mal eben zu bewältigen ist und
stellenzuwachs in diesem bereich
fehlanzeige
nur so wird man den herausforderungen
hier sicherlich nicht gerecht
und auch das bka auch wenn es 167 neue
stellen geben soll aus den reihen des
bka wird gesagt menschen wissen noch gar
nicht ob die stellen für die aufgaben
die wir im bereich cybercrime leisten
sollen ob die stelle überhaupt reichen
das bild was ich hier zeichnet ist da
wird einfach mal personal ausgekotzt in
zahlen stärke und keiner weiß was dieses
kanal machen soll ob es reicht ob es
ausreicht dass es blindflug sie wissen
nicht wo sie hin wollen und genau das
sagen diese aussage
und ich will immer zwei beispiele kurz
anreißen die verkehrsdaten speicherung
und wir sind uns einig jedenfalls die
union mit ihnen glaube ich dass wir
diesen ekelhaften sumpf der
kinderschänder in deutschland endlich
trocken legen wollen und genau das haben
sie im april diesen jahres gesagt wir
brauchen sie da sogar die
vorratsdatenspeicherung ihr zitat wenn
hat die ampel die anderen fraktionen
haben dann innerlich getobt und dann
haben sie irgendwann mal aufgebaut haben
sagt ja so wie es vielleicht gar nicht
gemeint schrieb die presse nur noch
bestimmte ip adressen sollen gespeichert
werden wenn wir aber der meinung sind
dass wir gegen kinderschänder reihe in
deutschland aktiv vorgehen wollen dass
wir den ermittlungsbehörden auch die
instrumente an die hand geben wollen
dann haben wir einen weg hier geboten
wir haben am 24 06 in den deutschen
bundestag als union einen antrag
vorgelegt der ist aber kategorisch
abgelehnt und stattdessen
aber man könnte ja meinen ok bekehrt
anderer weg alles gut
stattdessen aber jetzt vor wenigen tagen
beim herbstfest der sicherheitsbehörden
die aussage die wiedereinführung sei
aber im kampf gegen kindesmissbrauch
unbedingt erforderlich und es müssen den
ermittlern die instrumente an die hand
gegeben werden vor allem ministerin ich
erwarte jetzt auch mal dass den worten
taten folgen und dass sie auch ihre
fraktionen mal auf linie bringen wo
wollen sie denn eigentlich hin das ist
kein kurs und das hilft auch nicht
unseren ermittlungsbehörden und im
bereich aktiver cyber abwehr haben wir
ja das gleiche thema werden wir von
hacks geredet ich bin ein bisschen
verwirrt weil ehrlicherweise aktive
cyber abwehr auch mehr ist als der hack
beck aber aus ihrem mund soll das zitat
kommen im april gegeben das heck becks
und vermeidbar sein und fragen der
sicherheit dürfe man nicht ideologisch
angehen im juli dann aber berichtet die
presse frau feser lehnt pack becks ab
im april haben sie dann angekündigt bei
der grundgesetzänderung die notwendig
ist zb zentralstelle bsi sie wollen
zügig auf die union zu gehen um die zwei
drittel mehr zu beschaffen jetzt ist
fraglich ob die grundgesetzänderung uns
da irgendwie wie sie ich weiß es gibt
viele skeptiker aber wenn sie im april
sagen sie wollen schnell auf die union
zu gehen und es bis heute offenbar nicht
passiert ist dann frage ich mich was ist
denn ihre definition von schnell im
bereich kriminalitätsbekämpfung im netz
und auch verkehrsdaten speicherung
cybercrime sie haben jede position
mittlerweile mindestens einmal geändert
und wieder zurück und eine umsetzung ist
bis heute kategorisch fehlanzeige und es
finden oft geschrieben wenn man sich
informieren möchte cyber die unsichtbare
gefahr
ich glaube die größte gefahr für die
menschen und die sicherheit in diesem
lande ist eine unsichtbare
innenministerin in diesem feld
und es ist ja auch mein offenes
geheimnis dass sie dieses ressort nicht
gewollt haben das nicht ihre
leidenschaft bauen dass ihr ziel
vielleicht etwas weiter südlich in
hessen liegt der haushalt des
bundesinnenministeriums sinkt um 2,2
milliarden euro kann man ja sagen klar
wir leben in zeiten wo man sparen muss
aber ich erwarte jetzt auch
schwerpunktsetzung ich erwarte
durchsetzung autorität auch die
einordnung der ampel fraktionen oder
zumindest kompromisse die man bestreitet
im zuge von sicherheit die wir brauchen
in diesem land wenn der haushalt der
test der handlungsfähigkeit war dann
haben sie ihn auf jeden fall nicht
bestanden und das ist schlecht für die
sicherheit in diesem land es gibt sehr
viel nachzubessern an diesem haushalt
vielen dank
nächster redner ist der abgeordnete
stefan seite
vielen dank frau präsidentin die
kolleginnen und kollegen vor der
sommerpause haben wir hier im plenum und
im innenausschuss über die konsequenzen
der flutkatastrophe im aartal beraten
dort traf die kraft des wassers auf
einen überforderten bevölkerungsschutz
eine kraft und eine gefahr die die
menschen von nord und ostsee nur allzu
gut kennen deshalb vermisse ich als
vertreter einer küstenregion im bereich
bevölkerungsschutz einen wichtigen teil
nämlich den küstenschutz welche dämme
schleusen aber auch katastrophenhilfe
und ausrüstung schützen land und leute
küstenschutz ist auch immer
bevölkerungsschutz
wir wissen das aufgrund des weltweiten
temperaturanstiegs die häufigkeit von
hochwasser stetig steigen wird in 80
jahren auf 110 hochwasser jährlich an
unserer ostküste und an der westküste
auf 30 im jahr unsere kinder werden mit
dieser massiven bedrohungen leben müssen
der meeresspiegel an der ostküste wird
um einen halben meter ansteigen wenn wir
nicht in ausrüstungen im küstenschutz
und bevölkerungsschutz investieren dann
brauchen sie bald nicht mehr nach
venedig reisen steht wie flensburg
schleswig rendsburg oder auch viel tun
es dann auch ob sie dann noch so
sehenswert sind bezweifle ich sehr
entschuldigen sie meine norddeutschen
galgenhumor aber ist unterstreicht die
zunehmende angst der menschen in meiner
heimat liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
unsere nachbarländer machen es uns vor
während dort gerade ordentlich gebechert
nach geschaufelt und ausgebildet wird
machen wir leider zu wenig in diesem
bereich liebe ministerin feser wenn ich
diese gefahr gerade in ihrem einzelplan
anspreche dann weil die zuständigkeit
der bundesregierung in dieser frage und
klar ist in berlin im innenministerium
liegt der bevölkerungsschutz und im
landwirtschaftsministerium liegen teile
des küstenschutzes ich fordere sie auf
machen sie jetzt klare kante sorgen sie
für zusammenarbeit strukturen denn
später werden wir keine zeit für
kompetenzgerangel haben denn eines ist
gewiss das nächste hochwasser wird
kommen und ja wir müssen weiter auf die
kompetenzen der menschen vor ort
zugreifen die dringlichen investitionen
können sie aber nicht alleine stemmen es
kann auch nicht sein dass reiche
kommunen an unserer westküste sich neue
klima deiche und küstenschutz und
bevölkerungsschutz leisten können wenn
der ärmeren nachbar abläuft ich erwarte
von der bundesregierung in zukunft mehr
und ausreichende investitionen und eine
klare aufgabenverteilung im bereich
bevölkerungsschutz und küstenschutz die
menschen im norden setzen auf sie vielen
dank
stefan seidler war dass er ist mitglied
des südschleswigschen
wählerverbandes
deswegen fraktionslos und deswegen auch
als beratendes mitglied im ausschuss für
inneres und heimat
spricht der typen bis 90 die grünen sehr
geehrte kolleginnen kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger in europa ist
krieg und auch wir merken die
auswirkungen dieses krieges jeden tag
erleben die ausübung ökonomisch mit
angriffen auf unsere kritische
infrastruktur und durch gezielte
desinformation in unserer gesellschaft
für diese hybriden bedrohungsszenarien
brauchen wir den zivilschutz und
angesichts der situation in europa bin
ich der festen überzeugung dass wir
deshalb jetzt unseren zivilschutz das
thw unser bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz noch mehr finanziell
stärken müssen
denn wir wissen nicht was noch kommt
eine breite und gute vorbereitung lässt
uns handlungsbereit sagen egal auf
welcher welche herausforderung auf uns
warten wenn ultima ratio kommt müssen
wir vorbereitet sein
für diese vorbereitung müssen wir jetzt
mehr investieren einige kurze beispiel
aus dem haushalt im haushaltsentwurf
kürzen unter anderem die
krisenkommunikation die selbsthilfe
selbsthilfe und dem power nennt das kann
ängste abbauen die aus unsicherheit
resultieren und jeder einzelne von uns
kann souveräner in der in die krise
handeln geschickte krisenkommunikation
ermöglicht solidarität auch in der krise
niemand ist geholfen wenn lokal das
stromnetz zusammenbricht weil jeder
dachte jetzt den heizlüfter einschalten
das ist eine super idee
deshalb sind diese beiden haushalts
punkte entscheidend für gute
vorbereitung für diesen winter da müssen
wir nachbessern
hubschrauber dem zivilschutz fehlen
adäquate luft fähigkeiten kranken und
materialtransport werden dringend
notwendig gerade verlassen wir uns oft
auf die bundeswehr doch was ist wenn die
hubschrauber der bundeswehr andere
aufgaben erledigen müssen deshalb müssen
wir ganz konkret über mittlere
transporthubschrauber für den
zivilschutz diskutieren und wie weit die
szenarien reichen können das zeigt die
situation am größten europäischen
atomkraft wo keiner weiß wie es
weitergeht während die kugeln um den
meiler fliegen und gerade für diese
szenarien müssen wir unsere chemische
biologische und radioaktive nuklearer
abwehr stärken sollte es zu einem
zwischenfall kommen jetzt rächt sich
unser verkürzte kleinkarierter blick auf
das thema verteidigung die ausrüstung
der bundeswehr es wichtig und richtig
aber jetzt gerade in diesem hybriden
bedrohungsszenario brauchen wir doch die
fähigkeiten des zivilschutzes und wer
hat den zivilschutz aus dem
sondervermögen herausverhandelt die
union und die union hat damit der
sicherheit des landes ein bärendienst
erwiesen
jetzt gilt es unsere eigenen ansprüche
als parlament die wir ja in
sondervermögen gesetzt eingeschrieben
haben nachzukommen wir sind der budget
gebe ja wir entscheiden am ende und weil
einige hier wild alle kompetenzen
durcheinander würfeln feuerwehr kommunen
land katastrophenschutz länder wir
machen den zivilschutz und auch diese
aufgabe sollten uns auch konzentrieren
wir wollen uns handlungsfähig den
bedrohungen entgegenstellen und brauchen
deswegen einen starken zivilschutz
haushalt sehr geehrte kolleginnen
kollegen darum bitte ich um ihre
unterstützung im verfahren vielen dank
leon eckert war das und wir kommen zu
einem weiteren fraktionslosen
abgeordneten
mathias helferich auch beratendes
mitglied im inneren sehr geehrte damen
und herren scheiß lässt diese worte
veranlassten malte zwei frauen am rande
des münsteraner csds zu hilfe zu eilen
seine zivilcourage
bedeutete für ihn den tod geteerter
einer profi kampfsportler schuh team
gezielt gegen den kopf er ging zu boden
und verstarb später im krankenhaus der
csd killer jura die iaa ist muslimischer
tschetschene
vorbestraft und ausreisepflichtig wenige
wochen zuvor als die dortmunder polizei
ein vermeintlich 16 jährigen senegalesen
der sich und die polizisten mit einem
messer bedrohte aber der unterschied
zwischen beiden fällen ist es ist die
hierarchie der opfer wie es der autor
martin lichtmess nannte werden sie
schnell eine polit mediale welle der
empörung über die erschießung des
senegalesen formierte mann der polizei
strukturellen rassismus attestierter und
anti weiße kundgebung organisierte
schlägt das establishment zur ermordung
von walter bin deutsche opfer und fremde
täter sind vernimmt man nur
ohrenbetäubendes schweigen puffer haben
wir eigentlich ein früher beauftragten
der bundesregierung zehnten gerade mal
sehen sollen als er hess vortrug da hat
er nur mit dem kopf geschüttet ich
erwarte von ihm mal eine stellungnahme
ein millionenschweres
integrationsprogramm keine millionen
förderung der deutschen islamkonferenz
keine millionenschwere kampagne zur
förderung des ansehens unserer
sicherheitskräfte wird ein
gesellschaftliches kunstgebilde wie ihre
bunte republik zusammenhalten entwurzelt
fragmentiert von gegenseitiger fremdheit
geprägt und auch gewalttätig diese
unsichere zerfallenden gesellschaft ist
das produkt ihrer großen experimentellen
anordnung oder wie sie es nennen ihrer
großen transformation ohne ihre große
transformation wäre dieser
haushalterische pid überhaupt nicht
notwendig deutschland will keine
staatlich verordnete öffnung der
aufnahmegesellschaft kein rezept im
programm für afghanen kein schlachthaus
für tschetschenen werden und wenn sie
ihr multikulturelles projekt weiter
verfolgen wollen dann sollten sie
wenigstens so ehrlich sein auch sie
erinnern sich und ihre regenbogen fahren
um die farbe blutrot ergänzen vielen
dank
das ehemalige fdp mitglied matthias
helferich war das hilfrich für diese
für die formulierung dass wir ein
schlachthaus sind so habe ich es
zumindest verstanden dafür ruhig sie
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
peggy schierenbeck
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin nancy faeser
sehr geehrte damen und herren dieser
haushalt diese einzelplan 06 ist richtig
und wichtig er ist das richtige mittel
um eine moderne und fortschritt gewandte
innenpolitik zu betreiben wir stärken
die bundespolizei mit
1009 stellen wir stärken das bka mit 180
9 stellen wir investieren in die
sicherheit aller menschen in unserem
land wir investieren auch um die
cybersicherheit dieser bereich ist in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten so
wichtig geworden wie nie zuvor
im digitalen raum bestmöglich geschützt
zu sein ist so wichtig geworden wie nie
zuvor
ministerien feser hat es eben bereits
betont die förderung unseren befördern
unser bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz
aus katastrophen zu lernen es essentiell
jede flut jeder brand will die dürre
sollte uns anlass geben mehr in uns
schützende kräfte zu investieren besser
noch es gar nicht erst so weit kommen zu
lassen wir investieren auch mehr in
prävention
es wird uns allen klar sein aber ich
sage es gerne einmal prävention
verhindert mehr kosten als sie
verursacht prävention verhindert
mehr kosten als sie verursacht die
politische bildung ist schlüssel
maßnahmen im kampf gegen rechts die
statistiken zeigen ist uns das ist
momentan die größte in der
gesellschaftliche bedrohung gegen die
wir mit allen mitteln vorgehen müssen
lassen sie uns haben weiter eine
prävention in kluge und langfristige
maßnahmen investieren mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf zeigen wir wie viel
fortschritt in der sicherheits- und
migrationspolitik möglich ist wir machen
einen großen schritt in richtung zukunft
wir machen deutschland zu einer modernen
gesellschaft mit diesem haushaltsentwurf
beweisen wir was alles möglich ist und
in welchem land wir leben wollen wir
beweisen dass wir zusammen stark sind
meine damen und herren der haushaltsplan
für das bundesministerium des inneren
und für heimat zeigt uns auf dass eine
wirksame innenpolitik auch funktionieren
kann wenn konjunkturmittel auslaufen und
die schuldenbremse wieder kreist danke
über martin wir sprechen hier von
sicherheit für alle cyber sicherheit
katastrophenschutz
politische bildung behörden unabhängige
asylverfahrens beratung
sportförderung präventionsarbeit wir
geben sicherheit wir erhalten die
gesellschaft zusammen wir schützen
unsere freiheit und unsere demokratie
bildern
schierenbeck war das und hat hier diese
erste lesung zum einzelplan sechs
inneres und heimat beendet für das
ministerium von innenminister nancy
faeser die wir natürlich viele
verschiedene themen angeht aber unter
anderen wird sie sich eben auch um die
demonstrationen kümmern müssen die linke
hat ja schon den heißen herbst
angekündigt damit kommen wir zur
schlussrunde und
werden mal rein
karsten klein ist hier der erste redner
obmann im haushaltsausschuss
wir warten noch ein bisschen her klein
bis sich alle
wieso und das gibt uns durch die
möglichkeit zu sagen in welcher partei
und fraktion er ist er ist mitglied der
fdp-fraktion
wiegend der fall
und jetzt haben sie die volle
aufmerksamkeit herr klein ja sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundesregierung aus spd grünen und fdp
hat uns einen haushaltsentwurf 2023 mit
445 milliarden euro ausgaben vorgelegt
445 milliarden euro das sind circa 50
milliarden euro weniger als im laufenden
jahr
2022 aber das liegt vor allem daran dass
große
maßnahmenpakete hilfsprogramme die mit
der krise zusammen gerungen haben eben
auslaufen 445 milliarden euro das ist
aber auch deutlich mehr als im vor
krisen jahr 2019 das ist auch deutlich
mehr als alle finanzpläne vorgesehen
haben vor der krise oder auch der letzte
von der großen koalition aus 2021
zwischen 40 und 70 milliarden euro mehr
und das zeigt noch einmal dass diese
bundesregierung unter
bundesfinanzminister
konsolidiert das ist auch richtig aber
dass wir in keinem fall von einem
sparhaushalt reden was der ein oder
andere ja tun möchte liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen in diesem haushalt stecken
58,4 milliarden euro investitionen 18,7
milliarden euro kommen noch mal für
militärische beschaffungen oben drauf
und wir investieren in den klimaschutz
in digitalisierung in bildung und
forschung und in die
verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses landes was
in diesem haushalt aber auch drin steckt
sind die enorm gestiegenen zinsausgaben
2021 waren es noch 3,9 milliarden euro
zinsausgaben nächstes jahr plant der
bundesfinanzminister mit 29 milliarden
euro und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das zeigt noch einmal mehr es war gut
gott sei dank
haben wir nicht auf die ratgeber gehört
die uns weitere staatsverschuldung
aufgrund von niedrigzins und niedrig
oder negativzinsen schmackhaft machen
wollten gott sei dank im sinne von
zukünftigen generation
und deshalb ist es auch um so wichtiger
dass dieser haushaltsentwurf die
schuldenbremse einhält ja die
schuldenbremse steht in der verfassung
das muss man ja leider in diesem haus ab
und zu noch mal erinnert daran erinnern
aber ist es vor allem ein instrument der
generationengerechtigkeit
diese schuldenbremse art mit mit der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung mit sie
gibt uns die möglichkeit auch auf
schwierige wirtschaftslage zu reagieren
auch auf technische rezession im übrigen
und sie ermöglicht in
ausnahmesituationen zu agieren sie
kennen das aus den letzten jahren aber
sie macht vor allem eins sie
gewährleistet die handlungsfähigkeit der
bundesregierung und dieses landes um die
dauerhaften herausforderungen den
dauerhaften herausforderungen gerecht zu
werden da reden wir über den
demografischen wandel da reden wir über
die chancengerechtigkeit in der bildung
den sozialstaat aber vor allem auch um
das thema klimaschutz das sind
dauerhafte aufgaben die sich in diesem 1
der haushalt auch wieder finden und
diese dauerhaften aufgaben werden wir
nur gerecht werden können wenn wir auch
finanzielle solidität setzen die dass
diese bundesregierung tut liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn unsere
devise darf nicht sein dass wir die
probleme unsere probleme mit dem geld
zukünftige generationen lösen sondern
das müssen wir schon aus eigener kraft
schaffen
die schuldenbremse aber auch ein
instrument um die inflation zu bekämpfen
und dafür haben wir ja noch bausteine
auch in
entlastungspaket 3 eingebaut die kalte
progression wir haben aber auch
bausteine eingebaut wie einmalzahlungen
wie die absenkung der mehrwertsteuer auf
gas um auf die aktuelle lage das
aggressive vorgehen von vladimir putin
zu reagieren aber zu weit gehört auch
wir können nicht alles abfedern was bei
dieser energieproblematik entsteht wir
wollen not lindern und wir wollen
insolvenzen verhindert und wir wollen
dass strom und gas verfügbar bleib
unbezahlbar und der sack ist es liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen um so
beängstigend wenn der ministerpräsident
des größten bevölkerungsreichsten
bundeslandes diese hilfen den menschen
in diesem land nicht zukommen lassen
will das ist ein skandal wenn er diesen
fragen stellen übermächtig zu
werden für dieses paket starke schultern
müssen ihnen der krise auch mehr tragen
die länder haben starke schulter
zum schluss
die bundesregierung hat einen guten
haushaltsentwurf vorgelegt aber es gibt
keinen grund diesen entwurf noch besser
zu machen und ich freue mich auch die
haushaltsberatung
soweit karsten klein wir hier natürlich
angekündigt hat es gibt noch beratungen
das hier ist die erste lesung zum
entwurf des
haushaltsplanes und danach geht es da
noch unter anderen in den bundesrat und
auch in den haushaltsausschuss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bundesregierung ich möchte noch einmal
darlegen was uns als cdu csu in diesen
haushaltsdebatte wichtig war uns ist
wichtig dass wir alle maßnahmen
ergreifen um inflation energiekrise und
die kommende wirtschafts und finanzkrise
bewältigen die bürgerinnen und bürger zu
entlasten und die wirtschaft zu stützen
das ist für uns die hauptsache
wenn man sich nur ihr drittes
entlastungspaket anschaut das liegt ja
bisher nur als pressemitteilung vor
eigentlich ein unding wenn man sich
dieses entlastungspaket anschaut ist
klar dass vor dem mittelschicht nichts
drin ist die mittelschicht schaut mit
ihnen in die röhre und auch die firmen
schauen in die röhre es dieses paket ist
wieder nicht auf der höhe der zeit und
wieder nicht auf der höhe der probleme
nach dem was ihre pressemitteilung uns
mitgeteilt hat fällt dieses dritte
entlastungspaket durch mir hat ein farbe
geschrieben person machte eine
ausbildung in der gastronomie verdient
1200 euro und hat jetzt sind schlag fürs
gas erhalten
580 euro im monat mit der miete macht
das zusammen 1000 euro
die einmalzahlungen die sie vorschlagen
lösen das problem überhaupt nicht und
helfen auch nicht wirklich ein anderer
fall eine große firma bezahlt bislang 30
millionen euro für gas im monat 30
millionen im monat jetzt 160 millionen
um und es gibt kein geschäftsmodell her
wir machen uns alle große sorgen auch
den arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
helfen ihre 200 oder 300 euro
abschlagszahlung nicht sie sind nicht
auf der höhe der probleme und das ist
für uns als cdu csu ein großes problem
weil wir sehen dass sie mit dass sie
keine antworten auf die wirklichen
probleme dieses landes haben auf die
ganz akute krise
sie kündigen viel an und setzten wenig
um beispiel energiekosten dämpfungs
programm das sind 3200 anträge gestellt
nur 24 24 sind davon bislang positiv
beschieden übrigens erlaubt dieses
programm nur ausgleich für
kostensteigerungen bis maximal zwei
millionen euro wichtig für den
mittelstand aber da gibt es noch einen
großen eine große kluft ein großes spalt
die nicht bedient ist stattdessen hören
wir für symbolpolitik viel klamauk viel
selbstlob und ziemlich viel unsägliche
propaganda die mich empört weil sie die
sorgen und nöte der menschen nicht ernst
nehmen wann fangen sie endlich an zu
arbeiten
soforthilfe ist möglich sofort hilfe ist
nötig dass sie sind am zug sie regieren
das ist jetzt wirklich dumm gelaufen
dass sie regieren sie müssen die einfach
befinden wir brauchen hier schnellstens
gesetzentwürfe und wirkliche unterlagen
einmal mehr haben wir jetzt drei tage
lang einen haushaltsentwurf diskutiert
der makulatur ist in dem die
wesentlichen dinge wieder nicht drin
stehen ich empfinde es als beklemmend
das wird das getan haben ich empfinde es
als beklemmend dass sie am sonntag vor
den haushaltsberatungen ein
entlastungspaket vorstellen dass wir
nicht besprechen könnte sind haushalt
massiv verändert dass wir nicht
besprechen können weil ich wieder nicht
enthalten ist es tut mir leid ich kann
mich übrigens auch noch abrunden und
über die koalitionsfraktionen sie
bejubeln sie bejubeln einen haushalt der
hinfällig ist sie bejubeln ein vorgehen
der regierung dass diesen deutschen
bundestag riskiert dass den deutschen
bundestag nicht ernst nimmt ich habe das
schon beim letzten mal gesagt sagen sie
wenn sie die texte vorlegen sagen sie
auch die länder mitmachen über deren
köpfe sie ja einfach bestimmt haben und
sagen sie auch wenn sie den bürgerinnen
bürger endlich den über gewinn
zurückgeben denn der finanzminister an
der zapfsäule und andere gas mit den
hohen preisen erzielt uns ist wichtig
spieler mit zu erhalten für künftige
haushalte deswegen reden wir auch über
die nettokreditaufnahme das hat gestern
der kollege haase getan die rechnungshof
spricht der rechnungshof spricht frau
kollegin von einer versteinerten
finanzlage des bundes in seiner analyse
der schuldentragfähigkeit und rechnet
vor die netto kreditaufnahme liegt
tatsächlich bei 78 milliarden und eben
nicht bei 17 milliarden wie uns der
finanzminister gestern wieder in einem
alten manuskript versucht hat zu
verkaufen 78 milliarden und nicht 17
milliarden die zweite kollege klein ja
ganz tolle dinge heute von sich gegeben
in sachen schuldenbremse
da glaube ich haben sie die
unterstützung der union voll hinter sich
aber wenn man sich in die koalition
da gibt es glaube ich schlecht aus wo
steht die koalition bei der einhaltung
der schuldenbremse tatsächlich wir
können nur sagen nachdem was wir hier
sehen und sie stehen halt nicht dahinter
es wäre auch wichtig dass der
finanzminister vielleicht seine ideen
noch mal noch einmal bekräftigt das
letzte mal hat er gesprochen über
beschleunigung von planung und wir
wissen alle dass unser land unabhängig
davon wer regiert an dieser an der frage
von planungen und langen verzögerungen
krankt letztes mal hieß es es gibt eine
arbeitsgruppe wo ist diese
arbeitsgruppen und wo sind ergebnisse
ich glaube dass wenn man nicht mit
schlagzeilen regiert sondern mit
seriöser politik dann muss man hier vor
dem deutschen bundestag darlegen was man
sich vorstellt und nicht nur vor der
presse und jetzt komme ich beim
bundesfinanz kriminalamt des
bundesfinanz kriminalamt vor der presse
vorgestellt und hier mit keinem wort wie
kann so etwas sein wie kann es sein dass
wir über diese dinge hier nicht sprechen
und die dinge und die wesentlichen
inhalte aus der presse entnehmen müssen
ich war übrigens nach 15 jahren
betrugsbekämpfung auf europäischer ebene
nicht auf die idee gekommen dass in
diesem land gehörten fällen empfehlen
wir vielen kompetenzen für den
entscheidenden dingen ich möchte ihnen
sagen
kommen sie zum schluss geglückt
wenn man sieht was krise meist in der
krise zeigt sich wer ihr gewachsen ist
die union hat seit dem bestehen der
bundesrepublik gezeigt dass wir der
krise gewachsen sind dass wir mehr
können als schuldzuweisungen von ihnen
habe ich in dieser woche nur schulze
weise mit gehört da gibt es noch ganz
viel luft nach oben bei der frage wie
man dieses land aus der krise führt wie
man diesem land und seinen bürgerinnen
und bürger am besten hilft danken der
präsident
soweit die kritik von ingeborg gräßle
hier in der schlussrunde zum
haushaltsgesetz 20 23
ich war jetzt zweimal höflich aber ich
werde demnächst die redezeiten wie der
exakt einhalten und zwar gegen wir
jedermann und jederfrau und jeder person
nächste redner die ankündigung von
bundestags vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki und das heißt in seinem fall oft
dass das mikrofon abgestellt wird achim
post spricht jetzt für die spd fraktion
erst der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
präsident liebe kolleginnen kollegen
meine damen und herren wir
dürfen und das ist das gute frau
kollegin in diesem hause über alles
reden und wir reden über alles ich habe
die ganze woche verfolgt wie die
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesem hause
diesem haushaltsentwurf besprochen haben
und ich finde dass sie sich alle fast
alle sehr viel mühe gegeben haben diesen
haushalt sehr ernsthaft diskutiert haben
sehr ernsthaft geprüft haben wir haben
kontrovers diskutiert wie haben
teilweise sehr heftig diskutiert und
ehrlich gesagt darauf bin ich stolz dass
es in diesem lande möglich ist und
weiter möglich sein die aktive bewegung
und das ist dringender denn je denn wir
führen eine haushaltsdebatte in zeiten
des krieges und der krisen sich
überlappender krisen putins brutaler
angriffskrieg die sich zuspitzende
klimakrise und corona das nicht weg ist
weil wir uns wünschen dass es weg ist
das heißt wir haben eine menge zu tun
und wir alle wissen und das haben die
meisten auch gesagt das hat auswirkungen
auch auf uns auf die bürgerinnen und
bürger auch die beschäftigten auf die
betriebe auf die sicherheitspolitik der
bundesrepublik deutschland auf unsere
energieversorgung
und deshalb muss ich einen sagen nicht
alle haben sich an dieser ernsthaften
debatte beteiligt in dieser woche
es gab eine fraktionen die hat mal
wieder ein lied gespielt dass wir alle
kennen seit vielen vielen jahren das
lied heißt deutschland geht unter erst
wegen des euro dann wegen corona dann
wegen maßnahmen die wir jetzt zu
russland machen irgendeinem neuen rund
gibt es immer und ich sage ihnen eins
deutschland wird nicht untergehen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen denn
deutschland ist stark sozial und
demokratisch
und dann muss ich mal sagen diese
bundesregierung dieser
bundesfinanzminister wir haben einen
regierungsentwurf vorgelegt über den es
sich lohnt zu reden wie am ein
entlastungspaket vorgelegt aber dass es
sich lohnt zu reden und wir werden eine
politik betreiben über die sich weiter
lohnt zu reden die krisen reaktionsfähig
ist und die in zukunftsinvestitionen
denkt und zukunftsinvestitionen tätigt
wie noch nie zuvor in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deshalb
muss ich mich schon
wundern
dass sie liebe kollegen und kollegen von
der cdu csu weiter versuchen die
schwäbische hausfrau zu spielen das ist
sehr ehrenhaft und gleichzeitig eine
mehrausgabe nach der andern vorgang wie
das zusammenpassen soll ist mir klar
sid
sie fordern
die gasanlage zurückzunehmen das kann
man fordern das bedeutet für den
bundeshaushalt - 34 milliarden euro sie
fordern auf die rücklage zu verzichten
das kann man fordern bedeutet für den
bundeshaushalt 23 40 milliarden euro
weniger und wenn ich das alles
zusammenzählt und die zugspitze angucken
was sie da beschlossen haben da kommen
aber locker nochmal mindestens 40
milliarden dazu also alles in allem mehr
als 100 milliarden ich kann ihnen nur
sagen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
der weg vom kanzleramt ins
wolkenkuckucksheim war verdammt kurz
und dann gibt es noch was man darf man
darf er dann haushaltsdebatte darüber
einnahmen reden über die einnahmeseite
das ist erlaubt das verstößt nicht gegen
das grundgesetz
und diese ampel koalition macht
vorschläge wie die einnahmeseite weiter
gestärkt werden kann
die kennen sie alle die politik schlagen
politik gegen geldwäsche
globale mindestbesteuerung ja los geht's
genau das machen wir alles und diese
ampel ist der garant dafür dass wird die
dinge die lange liegen geblieben sind
endlich anpacken liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und zu europa
weil darüber müsste auf reden zu europa
die bundesregierung ist der garant dafür
wie viele bundesregierungen vor ihr die
viele bundesregierung vorher dass
deutschland stark bleibt und europa
stärker wird die kolleginnen kollegen
denn nur zusammen kriegen wir das hin
nur zusammen kriegen wir das hin und
deshalb muss ich mich schon sehr wundern
dafür braucht man pro europäische
regierungen dafür brauchen wir nicht nur
eine starke kommission oder eine starke
kommissionspräsidentin sondern pro
europäische regierungen und nicht
weniger in zwei wochen wird in italien
gewählt vor der tür stehen mussolini
eine koalition angeführt von george
romero nie eine rechtsextremisten von
salvini eine rechtspopulist unterstützt
von berlusconi gestärkt von manfred
weber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
fraktions und parteichef der svp ihre
parteien familie ich bin erschüttert
dass eine pro europäische partei die cdu
zu ross zulässt und deshalb unterm
strich unterm strich diskutieren wir
weiter ernsthaft auch sehr kontrovers
auch wenn es auch wenn es weh tut auch
wenn es ihnen weh tut die dinge um die
es geht denn dieser bundeshaushalt
dieser entwurf ist eine gute grundlage
es ist nicht das ende der debatte es ist
der anfang der debatte die vogue
regelschulen danken
es ist nicht das ende der debatte dass
es klar hat hier auch im post gesagt
denn wie gesagt gibt es noch weitere
beratungen im haushaltsausschuss im
bundesrat unter noch hier
[Applaus]
herr präsident wir haben in dieser woche
nun schon einiges über die
schwachstellen des haushalts gehört aber
viel schlauer sind wir nicht geworden zu
den großen rätseln gehört immer noch wie
die ampelkoalition ihr mythenumrankte
entlastungspaket den finanzieren will
oder wie sie die angekündigte strompreis
bremse operativ bekommen will wenn die
betroffenen stadtwerke die daten dafür
noch nicht einmal haben und das auch
ganz laut sagen ohnehin löst nichts
davon die
energieprobleme ursächlich es wird
einfach nur sozialistisch
planwirtschaftlich umverteilt
wissen sie eigentlich dass ist die
mittelschicht die das alles bezahlen
soll bald gar nicht mehr geben wird ja
herr post wenn sie das wie eben
geschehen ins lächerliche ziehen dann
zeigt das einfach nur wie unglaublich
arrogant die spd und wie weit entrückt
sie von der mittelschicht inzwischen
geworden ist
die insolvenzwelle ist schon unterwegs
und dennoch unterstellt der
regierungsentwurf ernsthafte im jahr
2023 wieder überschüsse im haushalt der
bundesagentur für arbeit und eine
rückzahlung der mittel in den haushalt
also die weltfremd kann eine regierung
angesichts einer direkt vor der tür
stehenden schweren wirtschaftsrezession
deutschland sein wie fakten resistent
ein fdp finanzminister gegenüber der
realität
anstatt die probleme dieses landes sind
der wurzel zu packen regieren filz und
ideologie der korona minister lauterbach
twittert ernsthaft zitat den größten
solidarbeitrag zur krankenversicherung
leistet die pharmaindustrie ihre umsätze
steigen stark
die fakten dazu hatte das mit den
umsätzen stimmt aber die weiteren fakten
bei kaiser wurde bestens verdient hier
forderte der bundesinnenminister jedoch
keinerlei über gewinnsteuern er macht
stattdessen eine dauerwerbesendung für
pfizer packs sowie die gkv dagegen
benötigt 2023 wegen der verheerenden
corona maßnahme folgekosten ein
bundeszuschuss von 17 milliarden euro
mit dem angekündigten
solidarbeitrag der firma konzerte von
einer milliarde euro hätten ja hätten
diese pharmakonzerne gerade mal fünf
prozent ihrer gewinne abgegeben und
selbst diese milliarde wurde am ende
entgegen lauterbachs lügen tweet wieder
zurückgenommen ganz zufällig entspricht
diese nun felde milliardär euro die
halter bach seine pharmafirmen erspart
hat genau dem darlehen das der bund nun
neuerdings der gkv aus dem haushalt
gewähren muss das lässt einen doch
sprachlos zurück
aber reden wir auch ein wenig über dem
grünen filz wenn die radikale klima
sekte aufstand der letzten generation
das sind die die sich immer wieder an
auf die autobahn kleben tatsächlich
hunderttausende steuer euros aus dem
wirtschaftsministeriums etr bekommt dann
ist auch das ein skandal
auch wenn das wirtschaftsministerium
offensichtlich nicht vertreten ist heute
ist bleibt ein skandal
gleiches gilt
gleiches gilt wenn eine grüne klüngel
ngo namens zentrum liberale moderne
unter anderem mit einer auftragsarbeit
für das kanzleramt namens gegneranalyse
mehr als eine million euro erhält um die
opposition im netz zu beobachten und
verteidigungsstrategien aufzuzeigen
grüne ngo allerdings arbeiten für das
damalige schwarze kanzleramt und nicht
zu vergessen die zitat leuchtturm
initiative des
entwicklungshilfeministeriums und der eu
damit stärkung der bürgerbeteiligung an
guter regierungsführung in laos und wem
dieser imperialismus im rahmen der
agenda 2030 der un als begründung immer
noch nicht genügt der sollte im
projektbericht schauen und dann erfährt
er dass es dabei auch um die vernetzung
und beteiligung aller gesellschaftlichen
gruppen geht wobei auch immer in jedem
fall aber unter expliziter
berücksichtigung aller 60 geschlechter
identitäten und selbstverständlich bei
zitat inklusion von transgender personen
also genau das was das entwicklungsland
laos zu braucht deutsches steuergeld in
allerbester verwendung
in deutschland und bei uns also
verweigert das finanzministerium dagegen
den menschen jede inflationsrate
erhöhung des steuerlichen
existenzminimums dfg fördert hier seit
monaten eine erhöhung auf 12.600 euro
button dass man für deutsche verbraucher
gibt es stattdessen die gasanlage mit
den faktisch zwei großen gas einkäufern
dieses verzockt haben seit heute ist es
noch ein dritter auch der wirt
milliarden brauchen und die werden
gerettet der eigentliche finnische
konzern juni per für den steht der
finnische stadt nicht gerade der
deutsche bürger rettet ihn nur dann
könnte man das aber auch so gestalten
dass das wenigstens auf kreditbasis
geschieht so dass juniper die über 20
milliarden die es letztlich aus der
gasanlage erhalten soll in ruhigeren
zeiten wieder zurückfahren muss es kann
nicht sein dass hier wieder einmal
gewinne bei wenigen konzernen
privatisiert die verluste aber über alle
steuerbürger sozialisiert werden letzter
seufzer verbrennt
der fdp-fraktion kürze diesem thema in
der nächsten plenarwoche eine debatte
erzwingen sie ist überfällig vielen dank
peter ehringer kündig das an und wenn
die jetzt vom wirt übertragen gegen auch
natürlich nur hoeneß spricht jetzt 90
denn liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
diese erste haushaltswoche diese erste
lesung hat sehr deutlich gezeigt die
rahmenbedingungen mit denen es diese
regierungen zu tun hat sind wahrlich
herausfordernd und nun schauen wir in
der schlussrunde auch immer so ein
bisschen auf die vergangene woche zurück
ich habe die debatten zum haushalt sehr
aufmerksam verfolgt und ich muss schon
sagen in richtung der union so langsam
habe ich den eindruck sie sind in der
oppositionsrolle auch wirklich
angekommen anders kann ich mir ihre
debattenbeiträge nicht erklären der
kollege post hat es hier schon erläutert
und ich will es hier noch mal verstärken
in sonntagsreden predigen sie die
schwarze null hier machen sie am
fließband neue ausgaben vorschläge ich
habe schon am anfang dieser woche gesagt
die grundrechenarten reichen um zu
wissen dass das nicht zusammenpasst mit
einer verantwortungsvollen
haushaltspolitik in dieser schwierigen
zeit wo wir gemeinsam in der
verantwortung stehen hat das überhaupt
nichts zu tun liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von
gleichzeitig war schon auffällig dass
für die unionsabgeordneten die atomkraft
dann auf einmal auch im einzelplan elf
steckte oder an anderen einzelplänen
immer wieder haben sie die atomkraft
hier beschönigt und beschworen in dieser
woche und damit einmal mehr bewiesen
dass sie unfähig sind aus der
vergangenheit zu lernen aus ihren
eigenen fehlern der vergangenheit zu
lernen aber ich möchte sie erinnern sie
haben in ihrer energiepolitik historisch
versagt sie haben uns abhängig gemacht
von putins russischen gas sie haben
gegen jede windkraftanlage gekämpft sie
haben bis zum schluss nutzt ihm zwei
verteidigt obwohl wir sie immer wieder
davor gewarnt haben vor den
energiepolitischen konsequenzen vor den
geopolitischen konsequenzen vor der
abriss barkeit nun wollen wir sie erneut
die kernkraft wird die preise nicht
senken sie ist ein unkalkulierbares
risiko sie trägt nicht zur
netzstabilität bei und sie ist eine
unbezahlbare hypothek für künftige
generation liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ihre altlasten lieber union
ihre altlasten sind mit verantwortlich
für die preissteigerungen mit denen wie
es jetzt zu tun haben während sie in
ihrer fraktion pro atom negativer
entwickelt haben hat robert habeck die
gasspeicher gefüllt die sie uns leer
hinterlassen haben sie tragen
verantwortung fangen sie endlich damit
an ihre energiepolitik an der
wirklichkeit zu orientieren und nicht an
kinder ideologie liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir wissen um die zumutungen in
dieser zeit deswegen haben wir eine
entlastungs paket geschnürt das die
ganze breite der bevölkerung abdeckt die
maßnahmen des dritten entlastungs
paketes greifen zum teil auch schon
kurzfristig beispielsweise die
energiepreis pauschale oder der
heizkostenzuschuss zwei beides noch in
diesem jahr andere maßnahmen wie das
höhere bürgergeld die wohngeldreform
oder auch die kindergeld steigerung
greifen dann im neuen jahr
insgesamt haben wir die menschen in
unserem land in der krise dann um
beinahe 100 milliarden euro entlastet
und das zeigt uns doch klar und deutlich
die ampel koalition nimmt ihre
verantwortung hier war in dieser
krisenbehafteten zeit und wir grüne
werden dabei weiterhin natürlich darauf
achten dass besonders die menschen
entlastet werden die es dringend nötig
haben das sind die menschen mit kleinen
und mittleren einkommen niemand darf
unverschuldet auf der strecke bleiben in
dieser zeit und das ist für uns die
handlungsmaxime und deswegen bin ich dem
finanzminister christian lindner auch
sehr dankbar dass er jüngst in der
süddeutschen klargestellt hat dass er
unter bestimmten umständen das aussetzen
der schuldenbremse tatsächlich dann auch
nicht ausschließt dass es für ihn kein
dogma ist und das ist natürlich richtig
denn es ist zutiefst pragmatisch die
schuldenbremse ist kein selbstzweck und
wir werden uns aus der krise nicht
heraussparen können dafür braucht es
eine aktive haushaltspolitik gerade vor
dem hintergrund letzte sieber tendenzen
und dafür sind wir bereit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der blick auf
den haushalt der
blick auf den haushalt
wir müssen auch grundsätzlich über
finanzierungsfragen sprechen die
abschöpfung von zusatzgewinnen ist
aktuell ein richtiger und notwendiger
schritt für den wir grüne uns auch sehr
stark eingesetzt haben wir sollten
darüber hinaus aber schon auch
konstruktiv über die frage debattieren
wie der haushalt schon die räume
erweitern können und da möchte ich auf
die summe der 65 milliarden euro für das
entlastungspaket zurückkommen 65
milliarden euro ist nämlich auch die
größenordnung und ich verweist er auf
einen bericht des umweltbundesamtes aus
dem jahr 2021 es ist die größenordnung
auf die das finanzministerium jedes jahr
verzichtet für fossile subventionen das
ist eine gewaltige summe geld und ich
sage auch ganz klar und muss
unmissverständlich wir können diese
subvention in dieser phase natürlich
nicht von jetzt auf gleich gleich
abschaffen das wäre preistreibend und
fatal in dieser situation was wir aber
brauchen und das will ich hier schon
diesen impuls will ich schon auch setzen
das ist ein fahrplan für den sukzessiven
abbau von klima schädlichen subventionen
das ist nicht nur der einzig logische
schritt im sinne des klimaschutzes
sondern eben auch um neue
finanzierungsspielräume zu sorgen für
gute soziale und klimapolitik führen die
vorhaben dieser regierung lieber herr
präsident ein letzter satz freue mich
auf die haushaltsberatung wir haben
spielräume wir werden sie nutzen
herzlichen dank so weit komme und meine
damen und herren sie sehen es wir
erwarten auf ein statement von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz zum tod von
queen elizabeth der zweite er hat schon
gestern auf twitter her
gedankt für ihren einsatz und
aufgeschrieben sie wird fehlen nicht
zuletzt ihr wohl noch voller humor bis
dieses statement komplett wir aber
natürlich in den beratungen zum haushalt
20 23
sind allein im august um 35 prozent
gestiegen die lebensmittel werden teurer
das neuen euro ticket ist ersatzlos
ausgelaufen für viele menschen spitzt
sich die lage immer weiter zu für die 14
millionen menschen die in armut leben
die zu niedriglöhnen arbeiten oder auf
die grundsicherung an und zunehmend auch
für normal verdienende und nun hat die
bundesregierung nach langem hin und her
ein drittes entlastungs paket
beschlossen indem sie ja zumindest mal
korrigiert haben das rennende rinnen und
rentner und studierende bei der energie
pauschale erst mal leer ausgingen was im
übrigen eine ungerechtigkeit
sondergleichen war eine einmalzahlung
ist sicher besser als nächster versuch
viele menschen werden damit nicht über
den winter kommen und deswegen brauchen
wir für kleine und mittlere einkommen
ein monatliches inflations geld das es
nötig und nicht die weitere steuerliche
entlastung für besserverdienende und
sinnvoller als den kreis der
wohngeldberechtigten auszuweiten wäre
ein bundesweiter mieten deckel ball dann
könnte man mietsteigerungen verhindern
statt sie auf kosten der allgemeinheit
aus zugleich meine damen und herren eine
wirklich sinnvolle maßnahme da würde
würden sie auf einen schlag millionen
von mieterinnen und mietern entlasten
unterm strich ist ihr entlastungspaket
enttäuschend es ist sozial unausgewogen
es ist nicht nachhaltig und das
kritisieren ja auch sozialverbände und
gewerkschaften menschen die auf
grundsicherung angewiesen sind bekommen
in diesem jahr überhaupt keinen cent
mehr gar keine hilfe mehr er hat mir
regelsatz soll erst ab januar steigen um
50 euro notwendig wären mindestens 200
euro pro monat damit die menschen nicht
in armut viele menschen wird auf die
tafeln angewiesen mit fünf euro 19 pro
tag für lebensmittel davon kann man doch
nicht leben meine damen und herren und
diese menschen empfinden spar tipps wie
die benutzung von waschlappen so recht
als absolut zynisch und das ist es auch
vor allem solange man mit 200
stundenkilometern über deutsche
autobahnen fahren kann weil die fdp ein
tempolimit für teufelszeug hält dann
sparen wir uns bitte solche absurden
spaß sich die die menschen bleiben
die wichtigste frage nämlich die die
explodierenden gaspreise die genommen
sie einfach aus keinen preis deckel ein
kostengünstiges grund kontigent keiner
maßnahmen gegen die spekulation
stattdessen führt die ampel eine
gasanlage 1 die ausgerechnet er weiter
dann die verbraucher und verbraucher
zahlen sollen die mit gas heizen worauf
jeder normale miete überhaupt keinen
einfluss hat wir sagen die gas umlage
muss weg wir brauchen ein verbot von
strom und gas sperren damit niemand im
dunklen sich oder ihren muss weil er
oder sie die rechnung nicht getan kann
und an der gasanlage haben ja
offensichtlich die konzerne fleißig
mitgeschrieben und dabei rauskam dass
nicht nur notleidende konzerne sie
bekommen sollen sondern auch unternehmen
die richtig gut verdienen die sich
gerade dumm und dusselig verging in
dieser krise weil es ist ja nicht so
dass alle ärmer werden kann allein die
mineralölkonzerne haben im letzten
quartal einen über gewinn von 38
milliarden gemacht und auch konzerne wie
rwe verdienen gerade gut andere länder
schöpfen diese über gewinne ab spanien
zum beispiel gerade über gewinn steuer
eingeführt für energie konzerne und
banken und damit finanzieren wir den
kostenfreien pnv dass meine damen und
herren ist sozial gerecht und das
klimafreundliche nicht die deutschen
wunders nun ist die allgemein bekannt
dass die fdp die schutzpatronin der
konzerne ist aber liebe spd und liebe
grüne sie können sich nicht bei jeder
frage und bei jeder sinnvolle reform
hinter christian lindner verstecken und
die fdp als grund anführen warum das
alles nicht möglich ist die spd stellt
den kanzler und nicht die fdp und wenn
sie die über gewinn steuer für sinnvoll
halten dann führen sie sie bitte 1
aber eine art ratgeber gewinnt steuer
die nämlich die bereits angelaufen jetzt
aufgelaufen über gewinne abschöpft
trauen sie sich nicht dran da konnte bis
zu 100 milliarden euro einbringen das
wir brauchen um die menschen zu
entlasten und auch um das neue euro
ticket zu verlängern und er kann es da
sagte ja selbst dass das neue euro
ticket eine der besten ideen gewesen sei
die die ampel je gehabt hat da sage ich
ihnen stampfen sie doch bitte ihre
schlechten ideen ein wie die gasanlage
und nicht die wenigen guten meine damen
und herren
die wollen die schuldenbremse einhalten
und verhindern gleichzeitig eine sozial
gerechte steuerpolitik damit verhindern
sie investitionen und dass es
unverantwortlich meine damen und herren
die gaskrise ist auch eine folge einer
verfehlten energiepolitik der letzten
jahre sehenden auges hat man sich
abhängig gemacht von fossilen energien
und damit auch von russischen importen
stadt die energiewende voranzubringen
und das kritisieren wir wir brauchen
eine energiewende und nicht das
festhalten an fossilen energie
verbrennt identität zum schluss letzter
satz wir brauchen druck in diesem land
in großbritannien haben gewerkschaften
und aktive gesagt nach rissen es genug
ist genug und streiten und kämpfen mit
protesten für entlastung für soziale
gerechtigkeit druck es auch in diesem
land notwendig soziale prozesse damit
sich was so gut
meine damen und herren
der tod der britischen königin
elizabeth der zweite bewegt und berührt
uns alle
weltweit ist trauer und grosser
anteilnahme zu spüren die kerzen blumen
vor dem buckingham palace in landen aber
auch vor der britischen botschaft in
berlin belegen welchem platz elisabeth
die zweite im herzen so vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger innehat auch hier
in deutschland
großbritannien hat seine königin
verloren die welt eine jahrhundertfigur
ihre regentschaft erstreckte sich über
mehr als 70 jahre eine halbe ewigkeit
die queen verkörperte das beste unseres
gemeinsamen europäischen erbes
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
ihr leben hat elizabeth zweiter ganz dem
dienst und ihrem auf steigende zinsen
und frau kollegin gräßle wenn sie bei
einem entlastungspaket von insgesamt 95
milliarden euro fragen wo bleibt da die
mittelschicht dann frage ich sie dir
gehört den aus ihrer sicht eigentlich
zur mittelschicht sind rentner keine
mittelschicht sind studierende keine
mittelschicht sind die menschen die die
kalte progression bezahlen müssen keine
mittelschicht das ist doch ein völlig
falsches verständnis von mittelschicht
ich war noch nie gehört dieses paket
richtet sich an alle die betroffen sind
und selbstverständlich auch in ganz
starken maße an die mittelschicht und
wir haben auch darauf muss hingewiesen
werden steigende zinsen 30 milliarden
euro im nächsten jahr die wir dafür
bezahlen müssen was zeigt dass
verschuldung heute in der zeitenwende
nicht mehr gratis zu haben ist dafür
übrigens allein für die steigenden
zinskosten der nächsten jahre muss man
im grunde die rücklage einsetzen das ist
volumenmäßig etwa der betrag die sie in
der vorgängerregierung noch für ganz
andere dinge eingeplant hatten also das
zeigt schon dass wir unter vielen
hier nochmal die worte von bundeskanzler
olaf scholz zur familie tod von queen
ist der zweiten noch einmal mit
besonderer würdigung auch was die für
die deutsch britische zeitungen dort
spricht gerade der parlamentarische
staatssekretär im
bundesfinanzministerium
florian toncar
beschäftigen müssen kann man eigentlich
das gleiche geld bessere ergebnisse
bekommen das ist auch die entscheidende
lehre aus der zeitenwende aus den neuen
rahmenbedingungen im haushalt die wir
haben und genau der verweigern sie sich
systematisch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union denn
ich habe diese woche bei 35 stunden
beratungszeit zum haushalt etwa 30
stunden hier auf diesem platz verbracht
und sehr aufmerksam zugehört und ich
kann nur eines berichten das wissen sie
wahrscheinlich nicht alle hier die union
fordert in jedem einzelnen einzelplan
mehrausgaben innen außen verteidigung
verkehr soziales wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung in jedem
einzelplan mehr geld aber kein einziger
finanzierungsvorschlag jeder weiß dass
das nicht geht was ihr hier vortragen
sie tun es trotzdem und das ist in hohem
maße unredlich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich denke übrigens dass gerade das was
sie hier diese woche auch gezeigt haben
ich muss wirklich sagen zu ihrer
verteidigung es gab einen
einsparvorschlag heute morgen der
kollege tom will einen
staatssekretärsposten im
innenministerium streichen der zurzeit
gar nicht besetzt ist also kategorie
albernheiten und im grunde das in der
tat was muss ich ihnen zugestehen aber
in wahrheit ist doch das was wir diese
woche gerade von ihnen erlebt haben als
die seriöse demokratische opposition
hier in diesem haus ist doch eigentlich
das beste zeugnis dafür dass dieser
haushalt grundlegend in die richtige
richtung geht es gibt keine grundlegende
anderen vorschläge wie man das geld in
diesem land anders ausgeben könnte außer
mehr für alles und das ist sicherlich
nicht genug liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und da muss man ja fast da muss
man ja fast die linksparteien noch in
schutz nehmen die wollen nämlich auch
mehr für alle aber die sagen wenigstens
dass sie dafür mehr schulden machen oder
mehr steuern erheben wollen das halte
ich für falsch aber ehrlicher ehrlicher
ist das allemal ist dass er sich von
ihnen diese woche gehört habe
wir stellen uns jetzt in der zeitenwende
unsere verantwortung wir treffen
entscheidungen beispielsweise der
koalitionsausschuss am letzten sonntag
weitere entscheidungen werden folgende
energie minister ist heute ja in europa
mit wichtigen themen befasst im kreis
seiner kollegen wir kommunizieren offen
wir sagen auch selbstverständlich gibt
es hier nicht die einfache lösung wer
einfache lösungen in dieser krise
propagiert der hat nicht die lösung
eines problems in sind er hat ein ganz
anderes spiel im kopf und davor kann ich
im sinne unserer demokratie nur warnen
vor nicht auf die haushaltsberatungen
kollege alois rhiel cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren diese
woche wurde der haushalt 20 23
eingebracht weil ich keine einfache
aufgabe in einer schwierigen zeit aber
meine damen und herren ich vermisse
ideen und innovationen für die zukunft
unseres landes und dabei haben sie auch
vergessen dass einen starken staat
einige ein tier regierung aus macht und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
appell von einigkeit habe ich in den
letzten tagen und wochen bei ihnen wenig
gespürt ein thema
zum entlastungspaket herr kollege komme
ich gleich noch ein thema die
entscheidung zur atomkraft verlängerung
ist in meinen augen ein witz oder dem
biogas deckel nicht aufzuheben ist das
gleiche wenn aus zum teils ideologischen
gründen nicht gehandelt wird dann kann
man sagen sie bringen unser land nicht
voran
und wenn sie jetzt wieder mit
altbewährten leider kommen wir waren ja
16 jahre in der regierungsverantwortung
ja das stimmt 16 gute jahre für
deutschland den vor diesem 16 jahren
waren wir das schlusslicht in europa und
in diesen 16 jahren kamen wir zu
lokomotive europas
und das und das mit einem ausgeglichenen
haushalts mit einer schwarzen null und
dem regelmäßigen ausgleich zum beispiel
der kalten progression und auch haben
wir schon in der opposition viele
vorschläge gemacht die sie leider gottes
immer wieder abgelehnt haben und eines
muss man auch dazu sagen in den 16
jahren waren zwölf jahre die spd mit
dabei mit führenden häusern und vier
jahre auch die fdp das wollen wir nicht
vergessen
meine damen und herren am wochenende
wurde sie
verzeichne den ausdruck ausbesserung
entlastungspaket mit vielen
ankündigungen vorgelegt es sind ja
einige gute vorschläge dabei bloß wenn
ich wenn ich eines höher ist es ein
volumen von 65 milliarden hat da muss
man der ehrlichkeit weil wir auch sagen
den bund betreffen gut 30 milliarden sie
müssen das noch mit den ländern und zum
teil mit den kommunen verhandeln das
hätten sie schon längst machen müssen
das haben sie versäumt das haben sie
versorgt sie machen den bürgern in
unserem land was vor mit den
entlastungen
ich bin mal gespannt was da rauskommt
ein beispiel das neue ticket in drei
monaten haus es nicht geschafft mit den
ländern ein nachfolgeprogramm
auszuhandeln dann zu den kosten drei
monate circa 2,5 milliarden über das
neuen häufig jetzt komme streiten oder
nicht neu geplant 1,5 milliarden euro
aus bundes seite und dann wollen sie
vielleicht noch die gleiche summe
ausländer seite noch mehr 1,5 milliarden
zimmer bei 3 milliarden ja wenn es dann
noch eine weitere drei monate oder
dreieinhalb monate eine entlastung
bringen oder wie soll es dann am ende
der tage lauf und ich sage ihnen eines
die menschen im ländlichen raum die die
möglichkeit nicht haben wie in den
städtischen gebieten den öpnv aus so zu
nutzen wenn du um fünf uhr morgens als
krankenschwester im krankenhaus arbeiten
muss denen sind sie egal oder sie sind
ihnen egal so geht es nicht meine damen
und herren sie vernachlässigen in diesem
entlastungspaket voll und ganz den
ländlichen raum
die mich scherben und hier der seite
unsere vorschläge liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe kollegin lagen lagen auf
den tisch und jetzt kam jetzt höre ich
hatte vorhin dass die mittelschicht
beziehungsweise der mittelstand
entlastet wird jetzt habe ich ihn mir
eines klar kann man dem vorschlag des
bundeswirtschaftsministers folgen und
produktion aufhören in den winterschlaf
gehen als bäcker und metzger ob dies
dann der richtige weg ist die sei dahin
gestellt aber es wird so nicht gehen wir
müssen die mittelschicht genauso
entlasten und die hart aber in die
mittelschicht genauso entlasten vor dem
ließ sich in ihrem programm relativ
wenig bis gar nichts und der mittelstand
der mittelstand die tragende säule
unserer wirtschaftlichen entwicklung ist
in diesem programm
0,0 erwähnt glaube ich nicht gesprochen
dass am ende der tage com ende
und ich gebe dem staatssekretär recht
wenn er das thema inflation anspricht ja
es ist eines unserer größten unserer
größten probleme die geldentwertung in
unserem land aber meine damen und herren
was machen wir dagegen was läuft dagegen
an ankündigung dass man das mary tor das
system ändern wollen das wissen wir doch
schon lange oder sie müssten es
eigentlich schon lange wissen dass der
strompreis durch die decke geht es
hätten wir schon lange machen müssen und
das hauptthema der überbordenden
inflation sind einfach mal die
energiepreise werden die
lebensmittelpreise noch mit dazu nehmen
an jedem lebensmittel hängt ein stück
weit auch energie trat sie hätten das
schon längst an tragen müssen sie haben
das nicht getan sie haben das versäumen
ich hoffe sie hören in den
haushaltsberatungen
auf die vorschläge der union die
vorschläge werden gut sein ich habe
größtes vertrauen in die haushalte ich
war da selbst einige jahre mit dabei
wünsche alles gute für die verhandlungen
für die verhandlungen tun sie es nicht
um ihre ideologie zu befriedigen tun sie
es für die menschen in unserem land
dankeschön
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin ist bettina hagedorn
die stellvertretene vorsitzende des
haushaltsausschusses und mitglied der
spd fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen liebe
zuschauer
ich bin
[Musik]
seit 21 jahren im haushaltsausschuss und
ich dachte ich habe schon viele krisen
erlebt mit der finanz und
wirtschaftskrise vor allen dingen 2008
2009 und mit den flüchtlingen corona und
es gab zeiten da habe ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen können dass es noch ärger
kommen könnte aber wir erleben genau das
jetzt weil die multiplen krisen stellen
diese regierung haben diese regierung
als sie noch nicht einmal 100 jahre 100
tage im amt war vor immense
herausforderungen gestellt die sie
hervorragend gemeistert haben und ich
weiß nicht lieber alois rainer du warst
nicht so viel im plenum diese woche die
ich weiß nicht wo du gehört haben wird
streit zwischen der koalition also ich
war genau wie der herr staatssekretär
über 20 stunden hat den debatten
gelauscht und ich muss sagen das war ein
fairer dass man gute beratung und
außerdem bitten sie nicht den eindruck
wir würden hier einen fertigen haushalt
beraten wir fangen erst mit den
beratungen
und meine vorräte haben schon darauf
hingewiesen dass er teilweise auf seiten
der größten oppositionspartei der
cdu/csu leider wieder eine relativ
fakten freie debatte erleben mussten und
damit werden sie allerdings dieses mal
ganz bestimmt ihrer verantwortung als
größte oppositionspartei in dieser krise
nicht gerecht wir brauchen eine starke
aber auch eine seriöse oder eine
anzunehmende opposition die letzten
haushaltsberatungen waren schon na ja im
haushaltsausschuss mit der union bahnt
sich in relativer ausfallen ich hoffe
dass es dieses mal besser wird und ich
hoffe dass die ankündigung von alois
rainer dass sie spannende vorschläge
einbringen werden auch der wahrheit
entspricht wenn ich mir aber diese
debatte an höre diese woche dann gab es
ja ein thema das jetzt nicht so ganz
viel mit dem haushalt zu tun hat das
haben sie ja richtig geritten das war
nämlich das thema atomkraft und
ich freue mich dass mein kollege bruno
höhle schon soviel dazu gesagt habe was
ich alles unterschreiben könnte aber ich
will noch ein faktum hinzuführen denn
der ausstieg aus der atomkraft von
rot-grün 20 jahre ungefähr her das war
ein vertrag und die energiekonzerne
haben ihn unterschrieben und weil sie
das getan haben und rot grün das so klug
verhandelt hat wäre es nicht möglich
gewesen regress auf kosten der
steuerzahler zu freunden und dann dann
kam die cdu fdp regierung und hat im
oktober 2010 die verlängerung der
laufzeiten
beschlossen und damit die verträge
aufgehoben und nur fünf monate später
kamen fukushima und hals über kopf haben
sie auf einmal das was sie fünf monate
vorher beschlossen haben wieder
rückgängig gemacht und wissen sie was zu
dass geführt hat das wissen sie
natürlich habe ich mir das noch mal der
öffentlichkeit sagen dass dadurch die
stromkonzerne die atomkraftbetreiber
dass sie dadurch in gresgen spruch hat
nur den haben sie eingeklagt und zwar
mit erfolg vom bundesverfassungsgericht
2016 und wer muss die suppe auslöffeln
in der letzte koalition in den letzten
unserer gemeinsamen koalition ein
finanzminister olaf scholz musste aus
steuermitteln 2,4 milliarden euro
bezahlen an regress eine stromkonzerne
vattenfall hat 1,4 erhalten rwe 880
millionen nbb 80 millionen und e on
preussenelektra 42,5 millionen das war
das ergebnis ihrer völlig
unverantwortliche politik und auch vor
diesem hintergrund müssen wir da keine
ratschläge von ihnen waren
und ja
ganz besonders wir haben ja in allen
bereichen mehr ausgaben gefordert aber
ich will mir mal zwei bereiche
herauspicken das eine ist die bundeswehr
und er tut es ihnen ja vielleicht weh
hoffe ich jedenfalls wenn ich ihre
erinnerung etwas auf frische dass es
auch eine cdu geführte fdp cdu fdp
geführte regierung war die sage und
schreibe bei der bundeswehr 8 milliarden
euro gekürzt hat 8 milliarden euro
dieses erbe haben wir dann mit unserer
zweiten großen koalition geehrt und wir
haben allein in den ersten vier jahren
von 213 bis 217 dann gemeinsam die
bundeswehr von 320 bundeswehr von knapp
33 auf 37 milliarden euro gestärkt also
um vier milliarden euro in vier jahren
und dann kam die nächste große und es
war eine gute zeit islam konjunkturell
gute zeiten und wir haben in dieser zeit
mit an finanzminister olaf scholz von 2
bis 2019 noch einmal sechs milliarden
euro oben drauf gepackt und wir stehen
jetzt dann kam ja die beiden
konjunkturpakete jahre da wurde es noch
mal gestärkt und wir sind jetzt bei
dauerhaften über 50 milliarden euro für
den verteidigungsetat davon hätten sie
nicht einmal geträumt und dann haben wir
noch das 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen beschlossen also das war
diese ampel regierung in diesem bereich
zugunsten auch zum zur sicherheit auch
der soldatinnen und soldaten angemessen
für die aufgaben für diverse button
müssen geleitet hat das haben wir mit
ihm so nicht hingekriegt
und dann will ich noch sagen die zahlen
habe ich hier schon vor zwei tagen
vorgetragen dass das gleiche für das
ministerium für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit gilt das
nämlich ist in der in ihrer
regierungszeit in der cdu fdp regierung
seit konstant bei 6 milliarden geblieben
sogar noch gekürzt worden und wir haben
es schrittweise in der großen koalition
auf initiative der spd und nicht auf die
initiative des damaligen gerd müller wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass der etat mehr
als verdoppelt worden ist und darauf
sind wir stolz und darum
will diese regierung
verantwortungsbewusst auch in
außenpolitischen fragen und haushalten
in diese schwierige zeit und alle haben
gesagt sie freuen sich auch die
beratungsstelle noch nicht ganz sicher
ob ich mich freuen soll aber wir werden
sie meistern
china
hagedorn war dass die spd-fraktion
nächste redner macht sich schon bereit
kein gottschalk der finanzpolitische
sprecher der fdp
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident verehrte
damen und herren hier im hause liebe
zuschauer
dieser vertrag in ihrer koalition hieß
mehr fortschritt wagen ich empfehle
ihnen den abtritt zu wagen das wäre für
deutschland gut und was ich jetzt sage
in richtung union hätte ich niemals
gedacht weniger fortschritt nein mir
rückschritt in einen gesellschaftlichen
finanziellen und wirtschaftlichen
bereichen hatten wir nicht mal unter der
merkel cdu meine damen und herren und
die krise beutelt inzwischen deutschland
wirtschaftsinstitute und klar adressiert
kann man den finanzminister und den
wirtschaftsminister der jetzt nicht da
ist aber sein staatssekretärs angekommen
die wirtschaftsinstitute prognostizieren
eine rezession die deutschland 150
milliarden euro kosten wird so schreibt
dass das handelsblatt gerade sie wollen
also ernsthaft an der schwarzen null
festhalten und im nächsten jahr an einem
ausgeglichenen haushalt wir werden sie
da an ihren worten messen aber das wird
ein blanker traum bleiben meine damen
und herren die politik der letzten
jahrzehnte liegt nun vor lebens kontor
alles was unsere partei die afb wovor
sie gewarnt hat eine verfehlte
energiepolitik eine verfehlte
migrationspolitik eine verfehlte
außenpolitik und eine verfehlte steuer
und wirtschaftspolitik schlägt nun voll
zu buche zur ezb will ich gar nichts
sagen meine damen und herren strom und
gas ist im supermarkt über alles so
teuer geworden durch das gas das wir
mittlerweile diese krise bis tief in den
mittelstand spüren mittelstands
entlastungen fehlanzeige
unternehmenssteuerreform fehlanzeige da
kam auch nichts von ihnen meine damen
und herren von der union und diese 300
euro meine damen und herren die sie dann
auch noch versteuern dürfen die sie
einmalig bekommen die sind für mich ein
almosen und einen hohen aber keine hilfe
meine damen und herren
und zum umgang mit anderen meinungen da
vielleicht mal an frau fieser adressiert
und die anderen damen und herren die
hier im haus also andere projekte
propagieren ich kann mich noch sehr gut
an die bundestagswahl erinnern da gab es
ein plakat grün am ist mieterhöhung
spritpreis krise strompreis explosion
diese wahrheit ich will noch mal auf die
sprünge helfen diese schöne plakat das
wurde natürlich von ihm und von ihm
hause als hetze bezeichnung es ist
blanke realität zeigt aber wie sie mit
andersdenkenden und vor allen dingen mit
der wissenschaft inzwischen umgehen
meine damen und herren
alles böse hetzer ich weiß meine damen
und herren eine wuchtige entlastung soll
das sein heraus gekommen meine damen und
herren dieser blaues lüftchen 95
milliarden in drei entlastungspaket
meine damen und herren die bild -zeitung
sie hat den weg zur tugend zurück
gefunden sie hat ja auch den greta
jüngern und anderen dingen dem
atomausstieg gefühlt übrigens vielen
dank für die krisenbewältigung vor
hagedorn meine damen und herren die bild
sagte der fleißige ist der dumme und
niemals hat ein wort mehr das brennen
das auf ihre politik gelegt meine damen
und herren
kein geld der welt wird das abfedern was
sie anrichten und diese regierungsbank
ist inzwischen die größte bank der welt
geworden meine damen und herren das ist
mal fakt
herbst ihr handeln als bundeskanzler ist
auch die hier bis bestenfalls genau so
lückenhaft und schlecht für ihre
erinnerungen fall warburg und comics als
lehrer würde man sagen glatte sechs
hinsetzen versetzung gefährdet während
in russland die öl und gas verkäufe mehr
als die kriegskosten einbringen das von
2,5 billionen rubel bilanziert das sind
etwa 41,3 milliarden euro meine damen
und herren halten wir an diesem
unsinnigen sanktionen festigung unserer
wirtschaft den menschen und unsere
demokratie schaden meine damen und
herren das beste das paket ist der stopp
dieser unsinnigen sie sanktionen und das
ist auch ihre schuld der bad bank bei
der damen und herren kommen aber auch
noch mal zu hören sind nach denn sie
tragen die hauptverantwortung dass sie
sich hier als mittäter und helfer
sozusagen beteiligen das ist schon
skandalös der bundesrechnungshof sagt
völlig zu recht die ware belastung sind
nicht mehr schulden von 17,2 sondern 78
milliarden euro sie verschleiern sie
tricksen meine damen und herren insoweit
kann man unseren finanzminister
mittlerweile als den größten
trickbetrüger der bundesrepublik
bezeichnet er ist besser als gar massa
legt er hat es nur auf 20 milliarden
gebracht meine damen und herren
spannend wird also insoweit sein wo sie
sprudelnde steuereinnahmen in den
nächsten jahren bei diesen insolvenzen
hören und ist gar nicht da der herr aber
ich hätte gern ein bisschen nachhilfe
gegeben an dieser stelle bei dieser
insolvenzwelle werden sie keine spuren
lohnsteuereinnahmen ernten meine damen
und herren hören sie also auf mit der
grünen transformation ist ein
rohrkrepierer und das comeback ist nicht
kann kleine empfehlung an die jüngeren
zuschauer gehen sie mal bei youtube in
das format junge naiv hier könnte man
sagen alt und naiv dass stammelt dieser
bundeswirtschaftsminister völlig wehres
zeugs wie zu basel 3 keine ahnung war
kam wusste er genau die bafin prüft
handwerkerrechnungen herzlichen
glückwunsch da ist diese insolvenz
entgleisung ja noch harmlos gegen meine
damen und herren also insoweit ist der
beste beste schritt für unser land
machen sie den platz frei für eine
vernünftige regierung und treten sie
zurück
die übersetzung sie mit dem jahr acht
sekunden sofort ansonsten verstehe ich
jeden bürger der auf die straße geht und
gegen diese unsinnige politik
demonstriert das ist ihr recht und sie
sind deshalb keine rechten weil sie ihr
recht und kaufen meine damen und herren
wir freuen uns auf die beratung kollege
kommen sie jetzt zum schluss drehten
dabei ist vorbei
bei uns sind sie immer sehr genau also
wenn ich mit 28 sekunden drücken wir
sehr genau hin denn es ist etwas was sie
vielleicht noch lernen sollte
ich will nur darauf hinweisen dass ich
das zumindest die und parlamentarischer
ein mitglied der bundesregierung zum
trickbetrüger zählen denn nicht legt
noch einmal nach ich bei ging eine
ordnungsmaßnahme vor
felix bündnis 90/die grünen
er präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
herein es ist ja in jeder beziehung gut
wenn man auch mal fragen stellt aber sie
haben ja nur fragen gestellt und keine
einzige antwort gegeben und das von der
opposition die so lange regiert im frau
christa sie haben gesagt sie erwarten
dass diese regierung gesetzespakete
gesetzentwürfe vorliegt dass wenn ich
ihre aufgabe ich will sie mal daran
erinnern es gab hier 16 jahren
opposition die hat sogar gesetzentwürfe
vorgelegt man kann nicht nur
unterschiedlich gut regieren man kann
auch unterschiedliche opponieren
offensichtlich
meine damen und herren frau wissler
sie haben mir gerade ein paar punkte
angesprochen was die sozialen fragen
dieser zeit angeht auf die ich gleich
noch mal genauer eingehen werde aber sie
haben ganz spannender weise ein paar
punkte und ihre räder ausgelassen
beispielsweise warum sie ihr sagen man
müsste doch viel schneller aus den
fossilen energien aus den fonds ihren
abhängigkeiten aussteigen und ihre
fraktion sich gestern entschieden hat
sahra wagenknecht den einstieg in neue
fossile abhängigkeiten faktisch zu
fordern durch das ende der sanktionen
und damit auch durch die inbetriebnahme
von nord stream 2 was wollen sie nicht
fossile abhängigkeiten überwinden oder
fossile abhängigkeiten forcieren und uns
noch weiter von kriegsverbrecher bertino
putin treiben lassen das ist die planung
die sie beantworten müssen
und ich hatte gestern ja an dieser
stelle ich hatte an dieser stelle ja
dass ein wortwechsel verwarnt licht und
herrn ernst seitdem häufen sich bei mir
in den sozialen medien die hass
kommentare die bedrohungen wenn mal
jemand wenn ich mal wieder in
nordrhein-westfalen bin mit dem fahrrad
könnte es zu einem unfall kommen und
jetzt sagen sie vermutlich das wäre
unfair und es wäre unredlich sie in
verbindung mit diesen dingen zu setzen
nur weil das zufälligerweise passiert
nachdem sarah wagenknecht und nicht
miteinander gesprochen haben dann möchte
ich sie fragen wie kann es sein dass
ihre fraktionskollegin sylvia dann vor
der parteizentrale der grünen
demonstriert und sagt die eigentlichen
adressaten in dieser zeit seien annalena
baerbock und robert habeck diese
wirklich irrlichternde beschämende
relativierung der kriegsverbrechen
russlands die können sie doch nicht
hinnehmen wenn sie das leid der menschen
wenn sie die sorgen die berechtigten
sorgen der menschen davor ob sie sich
die stromrechnung noch leisten können
instrumentalisieren für diese
außenpolitische ihre fahrt dann haben
sie auch ihre verantwortung nicht ernst
genommen
meine damen und herren
ich mache mir sehr große sorgen ich
mache mir sehr viele gedanken über die
sozialen fragen dieser zeit ich weiß
nicht keiner kann das heute wissen ob
das entlastungspaket 123 ausreichen wird
um alle probleme die menschen haben zu
bewältigen ich kann ihn aber eins lagen
diese bundesregierung wird nicht
aufhören sich über diese fragen gedanken
zu machen und wenn es notwendig ist
daraus auch die konsequenzen zu
ergreifen wenn dieses dritte
entlastungspaket nicht die letzten
fragen beantwortet dann wird es auch
nicht die letzte entlastung dieser
bundesregierung gewesen sein
und in dieser aktuellen situation in der
die installation hier eine
unbestreitbare tatsachen und auch eine
große gefahr ist sowohl für menschen mit
wenig einkommen aber ja am ende für alle
und diese installation natürlich auch
ein volkswirtschaftliches risiko und
trägt möchte ich trotzdem die
aufmerksamkeit auf eine andere gefahr
lenken wir haben heute die ankündigung
gelesen überall dass die ezb ihren
leitzins erhöht hat das bedeutet dass
wir sozusagen geldpolitisch rezessions
dynamiken wahrscheinlicher erleben
werden und wenn wir jetzt als
haushaltsgesetzgeber uns fragen was
unsere aufgabe dann in dieser situation
ist dann müssen wir uns auch die frage
stellen was können wir tun um rezessions
dynamiken ein bisschen weniger
wahrscheinlich zu machen und das
bedeutet dass wir unsere
wirtschaftspolitik unsere fiskalpolitik
diesen veränderten realitäten anpassen
werden und meine damen und herren in
dieser situation
in der ja nicht nur viele menschen mit
dem rücken zur wand stehen sondern viele
unternehmen sich fragen können sie
demnächst noch produzieren sind die
produktionskosten wegen der strom- und
ja deswegen ja wegen der gaspreis
explosion eigentlich noch ausreichend zu
bewältigen dann ist es doch vollkommen
klar dass eine soziale antwort auf diese
und auch eine ökonomisch kluge antwort
auf dieses multiple krisenszenario mit
inflations und rezessionsgefahren eine
kleine konjunkturpolitik sein muss die
am ende dazu führt das unternehmen noch
produzieren können weil wenn unternehmen
produzieren zahlen sie steuern wenn
unternehmen produzieren gibt es menschen
die in unternehmen arbeiten die zahlen
dann wiederum steuern wenn wir einen
ausgeglichenen
und wenn wir einen stabilen haushalt
auch in der zukunft haben wollen dann
brauchen wir eben auch die
wirtschaftliche basis die auf der
einnahmenseite dafür sorgt dass die
ausgaben die notwendig sind auch
finanziert werden können in diesem sinne
freue ich mich darauf dass wir
konstruktive haushaltsberatung auch
dieses mal an dieser ampel haben werden
ich bin gespannt ob die opposition
diesmal noch ein bisschen kreativer und
origineller und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen gegenfinanziert wird als beim
letzten mal vielen dank
sagt felix bender von den grünen und
schon auf dem weg zum podium ist otto
fricke fdp haushaltspolitischer sprecher
seiner fraktion
aufgerufen wird bevor man bekommt aber
sie haben jetzt das wort herr kollege
fricke fdp fraktion ich habe sie gespürt
geschätzter herr präsident dass sie um
alle gebeten haben die kollegin kollegen
schlussrunde ausblick auf die
haushaltsberatungen da ist noch nichts
angefangen deswegen was da von seiten
der cdu zu der frage außer frage kommen
ist eigentlich die selbstentmachtung
wenn man meint dass das parlament nicht
der gesetzgeber sei ich will auf einen
punkt ganz deutlich im haus nehme sap
das thema inflation inflation ist ein
falscher freund des haushaltes wir
glauben jetzt da kommen massenhaft viele
einnahmen wir erkennen aber auch
gleichzeitig als haushälter da kommen
ganz schön viele aufgaben auf uns tun
deswegen die rettungspakete deswegen
vieles andere mehr aber ich will
inflation in das verhältnis auch noch
zum thema schulden stellen wenn wir eine
steigerung der inflation haben wenn wir
die auswirkungen auf die zinsen haben
kommt der falsche freund inflation ganz
schnell angetreten das werden wir in den
nächsten jahren noch erleben deswegen
ist es auch eine aufgabe sparsam zu sein
aber eben nicht geizig und das gehört
zur haushaltspolitik dazu und dann
möchte ich uns alle nochmal ermahnen
dass wir sparsam nicht als geizig
verstehen sondern als vernünftig und
gleichzeitig wenn wir uns die
schuldenbremse angucken auch als etwas
was und da gebe ich dem kollegen man
vergleicht was auch gleichzeitig
rezession bekämpft und deswegen hat
diese schuldenbremse von der alle immer
behaupten sie wer statisch oder andere
einen schwarzen null fetisch haben
deswegen hat sie eine konjunktur
komponente und ich sag das auch noch mal
für diese koalition da steht nicht es
bleibt bei der neuverschuldung wie sie
im entwurf steht sondern es bleibt bei
der neuverschuldung die uns die
schuldenbremse erlaubt und wenn die
konjunktur noch weiter runter geht wird
das auch auswirkungen auf die show
bremser haben und da bin ich mir sicher
dass wir dann auch genau sehen werden wo
die jeweiligen auswirkungen sind denn
das habe ich in diesen debatten bei
aller kritik an der cdu csu in der frage
der gegenvorschläge dann doch erlebt das
ist die menschen wichtig sind dass sie
uns am herzen liegen dass wir spüren
welche ängste da sind das bezweifle ich
für diese vier fraktionen überhaupt
nicht an der stelle das ist das was uns
treibt dass uns das was übrigens allen
angst machen das glaube ich auch für
linke und rechte ich glaube nur dass sie
andere profi pläne damit haben zum
schluss meine damen und herren ich freue
mich auf die weiteren
haushaltsberatungen und weil ich heute
wegen den kleinen elias nicht mit
shakespeare enden will tui es lieber mit
goethe und hat noch mal eine bitte an
die cdu csu fraktion nimmt doch einmal
eure reden hintereinander gerade eben in
ihnen wieder zwei milliarden werde der
nächste redner der cdu sagt er gibt aber
zu viel geld aus bringt es in eine linie
sonst ist es wie beim chor von faust 2
das unzulängliche hier wird's ereignis
herzlichen dank
dank natürlicher theke
der kollege florian oßner cdu csu
fraktion kann darauf ja gleich an worden
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
möchte so otto fricke antworten es ist
schon echt mutig es ist schon wirklich
mutig was hier der herr
bundesfinanzminister jetzt in
stellvertretung der staatssekretär
florian trinke heute uns als hausautor
vorlegt mutig deshalb weil man sich
verwundert die augen reibt was hier
alles nicht zusammen passt so ruft die
bundesregierung seit wochen die
bürgerinnen und bürger auf zum verzicht
weniger duschen weniger heizen weniger
auto fahren und und und und was machen
sie im gegenzug
10.000 zusätzliche posten im ministerium
eine ungezügelte verschuldung und eine
desaströse krisenpolitik
es ist ist es daher mehr als sehr
zweifelhaft wie sie liebe ampel
versprochene leitlinien also keine
steuererhöhungen und einhalten der
schuldenbremse am ende einhalten wollen
spätere erinnerungslücken
erinnerungslücken aller herrn
bundeskanzler erlauben wir hier als
haushälter und als unionsfraktion nicht
also mehr wasser predigen und wein
trinken geht wahrlich nicht stoppen sie
diesen wahnsinn
bestes bestes beispiel auf welch
wackeligen fundament der gesamte
haushalt gebaut ist das sogenannte
dritte entlastungspaket ist es überhaupt
nicht in dem haushalt eingepreist 65
milliarden euro eine gigantische summe
soll es kosten keiner weiß jedoch wie
sich diese gigantische summe
zusammensetzt entlastung von
normalverdienern und von
mittelständischen betrieben fehlanzeige
wieder einmal hat die die
selbstständigen die handwerker die
freiberufler und die kleinen und
mittleren unternehmen vor allem auch im